three
times
I'll let you taste the power of my fists
ask me
foreign
[Music]
what's your status
and do these creatures have to attack
this facility these are mere drones then
what guides them a worthy adversary
who will pay you what a copy
all right
official rate this abomination
delta wing report the spores collapse
the bridge there's no way through get
into assault position by the bridge
let us show them some of ultimate
hospitality
come forth and be slaughtered
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
you have died and been Reborn
we need to find a way to get you inside
without being seen
you could bribe the guards to look the
other way I shall see what flavor best
suits me
[Music]
embrace the fear
quiet it find the Stillness
let's go
the stage is your spasm
[Music]
we will be watching
thank you
don't say his name
I can hear you
he's always listening
[Music]
last night I dreamed that my uncle hung
himself in the Attic that we were too
late
[Music]
it was still called their setup
definitely a weird place it feels like
I've been here before I just can't think
why let's not waste any time detective
yeah me right let's go get your uncle
Miss Hartwood
it transports you into the dark
Alleyways and into the nights I mean
it's always trying to create a mystery
right something that's more than just
jump scares
a bit of fighting demanding puzzers and
a lot of atmosphere
that maintain some of that weirdness of
the old games but it had like an updated
slickness to it that I liked as well you
haven't seen a little girl by any chance
have you I don't think so uh you would
have known if you did
we start our story much like the
original Jeremy Harwood is haunted by
the dark man and he goes to a
Countryside Hospital called josetto and
hope to find some help
I need to get this letter to my niece
she would understand
Jeremy sends a disturbing letter to
Emily Harwood his niece and it Spooks
her enough that she hires detective
Edward carmby to find out what's going
on who are you whoa pardon me excuse me
my name is Edward carnby private
investigator I hope you don't mind we
let ourselves inside I do mind we knew
early on that we had a character driven
story so we needed to find some really
good actors to make those characters
come to life
I knew of past iterations of the game I
mean the Video Game World is something
that I'm very interested in in general
the horror game genre specifically
David has a really strong presence as an
actor and he's able to make the funny
moments really funny but also the
dramatic Parts really intense why the
hell do I wake up hearing that damn
voice
[Music]
detective and he's like searching for
something and you know he's uh he's
hard-boiled but he's got some humor to
him and stuff like that he's a bit of a
Trope or a type and I like that and I
like the world and sort of how he's
exploring this Insanity
um amidst all this horror and stuff I
liked all those aspects let me know if
you find her are they around
[Music]
Emily Hartwood has a closer connection
to the plot as she is Jeremy's niece and
therefore also suffers this strange
Affliction known as the hardwood cross I
love the mystery of the game
um I love the picture of her like there
was so much about it that I was curious
of
there's a lot of fear within her and a
lot of speculation and curiosity and
um I guess
dread Intrigue like there's there's a
lot about hair that is
um kind of on edge
10 years now more even since he died
he got a hero
Jody's a fantastic actress and she
brings a lot of nuance to Emily as a
character and it really makes us
sympathize with
who's in here
show yourself
every element but then she still has to
go on a journey and discover different
things and they should still be room to
breathe and have a funny moment or a
sarcastic moment or a moment of
Discovery and so it's just trying to
really kind of keep all those other
beats alive amongst the
um the kind of Darkness of it all I
guess is how I felt anyway
bringing back both Emily and Edward as
the playable characters and depending on
who you play you will get a different
take on the same story
the people at reset it will react
differently to you depending on who you
play
even the story will be slightly
different what are you doing sneaking
around so you should definitely make
sure to play the game twice
foreign
game was basically looking at the
original and it feels like we've been
cultivating a seed that was planted 30
years ago and it has now grown into
something even more dark even more
Sinister
I remember that with the first one in
the dock I met in 1992 we were basically
doing something that nobody had done
before it was the first time that we
could explore a big mansion fight
monsters and solve difficult puzzle all
in real time Swedish
[Music]
at the core is a haunted mansion that's
the most important part it's dorsetto I
would say
feeling that you're entrapped inside
uh kind of small space yeah I used to
say back in the old days that it was
another character yeah for sure
with all the remakes going on today you
are never sure what you get at the end
I think that Mikhail and the team at PCS
did a great job preserving the core
feeling of the game they even went
further than everything I could expect
30 years ago it's really an honor to
sort of be a part of the franchise in
that sense because it is such a again it
can't be overstated it's so special it
was such a new experience
as a fan of the original I wanted to
bring as much as I could into our
version and they might have a slightly
different meaning and different reasons
to be there but if you know the old
games you will find a ton of references
do I know you from somewhere
I remember you Mr convey
I feel the franchise is in good hands
now and I can't wait to play the full
game
[Music]
to give you a taste of what the full
game will be we also created a prologue
and it features a character from the
game called Grace Saunders who is a
little girl and you play as her walking
around your Shadow and trying to post a
letter
[Music]
the prologue is the first glimpse into
the atmosphere and the mood and of
course the story of the full game so if
you want to have a look go and download
it right now they're so creepy
[Music]
our combat is intense and tough and you
will need to use every bullet you can
find and if you run on bullets I'm out
of bullets you might need to get in
close
or if you're lucky you can find
something to throw
as mentioned before your job is to find
out what happened to Jeremy hardwood and
to do that you will need to visit some
unexpected places and to get to those
places you need to find Clues and solve
some interesting fossils
depending how much you feel like a
detective yourself you can choose how
much you want the game to help you find
Clues and where to go next
so the biggest creative Focus for me as
for a long time been to reach something
armed the mundane
something spiritual
Mike the director and I we spend a lot
of time trying to figure out what
direction musical direction we want to
take in this project and when we finally
decided to
go for this kind of dark green Jazz
Direction our minds went directly to
Jason who is a master in this genre it's
a very visual uh genre of music the fact
that it's inspired from noir films or
Noir detectives is already a good
explanation of why this music fits very
well for um along in the dark
huge mountain and volcano of of Reverb
with drums and screaming saxophones
[Music]
explosion of the hair Rising horror and
and
big chaos
as the players drawn deeper into the
game role they will face off with the
Sinister presence known as The Darkness
the Dark Men isn't real Jeremy there's
nothing you can do to hurt you how do
you think any of this is happening how
do you still not trust my words
fine then let me help me foolish he will
bury you next to me in his sunken Temple
for an eternity
real or not something is definitely
corrupting the mind of Jeremy Markley
and something very very dangerous
[Music]
Street Fighter 6 has learned lessons
from the content Bear release of its
predecessor and offers a variety of
significant features and modes right out
of the gate it's a robust fighting game
that is a premier quality a return to
form for the franchise that welcomes
both new Fighters and seasoned Pros
356 splits this content into three hubs
fighting ground which most closely
emulates the classic street fight
experience battle Hub where players can
congregate and challenge each other to
compete in tournaments and World Tour
which is a sprawling story mode with an
open world and RPG hooks each gameplay
format centers on the classic Street
Fighter style of 2D fighting gameplay
and that excellent core experience is
what drives everything
mechanically Street Fighter 6 doesn't
fall far from previous games in the
series you have multiple normal attacks
special attacks super arts and movement
techniques specifically designed for
each of the roster's 18 characters what
distinguishes street fighter 6 from
previous iterations are the core
Universal mechanics shared by all
characters these Universal mechanics are
also where much of street fighters use
gameplay depth is the drive system is
356's new Universal battle mechanic and
I'm amazed at how much it adds despite
being simple to grasp by pressing the
two medium attack buttons I can Parry an
attack using Drive power free or with
Drive rush I can immediately Dash
forward out of it for a burst of speed
that can catch opponents off guard or
introduce new combo sequences
functionally players that are
experienced with three fighter 4's Focus
attack Dash cancel all kill against
Roman cancels will feel right at home by
pressing both heavy attacks I can
initiate a drive impact that can stagger
an opponent and leave them open ensuring
that overly defensive players can be
opened up if an opponent is backed into
a corner Landing this will make him
Bounce Off the Wall adding a variety of
other strategic considerations and
opportunities Drive reversals meanwhile
allow me to block an attack and counter
with a move that while not very damaging
will help Escape tricky spots and
finally overdrive lets me power up
special attacks like the EX system of
old
these aren't unlimited however as each
move uses up part of the drive gauge
just below the health bar and a fighter
can burn out which slows their movement
speed and makes certain offensive and
defensive moves inaccessible for a
period the Strategic implications of
this system cannot be overstayed as
these new tools do wonders for the
overall fighting drive impact in
particular can swing the tide of the
battle in an instant as catching an
unsuspecting opponent with one will
allow you to put a hurting on them
keeping these tools in front of your
mind is key to Victory and luckily it's
not an overwhelming amount to recall one
of the major criticisms leveled at s355
was the rigidity of battles with some
going so far as to call it turn based
however these new mechanics make stream
fighter 6 feel more fluid
okay oh no matter how simple Street
Fighters can seem novice players are
going to feel some trepidation when
stepping into the ring for the first
time the game is ready for you though as
Capcom has implemented a new modern
control scheme that makes controlling
Fighters more like Super Smash Brothers
than a traditional Street Fighter this
gives new players a foundation from
which to learn but that growth does have
a ceiling if you decide to transition to
the classic control scheme players will
need to learn the manual input controls
that have been used since Street Fighter
2. the easiest place to learn 356 either
in modern or classic Styles is in
fighting ground which is a traditional
street fight experience this is where
you'll find familiar modes like arcade
mode online ranked and Casual matches
and offline versus modes this section's
shining feature however is its practice
area which houses some of the best
in-game tutorials the series has ever
had practice mode has the classic
freeform training mode fans expect but
also holds full tutorials for the game's
core systems as well as character guides
and combo trials for all 18 characters
on the roster these character guides are
a deep dive into what makes each fight a
tick as it explains not only their
special moves but also the best
situations in which to use them fighting
ground also lets you Tinker with in-game
commentators one of the more balihood
features of Street Fighter 6.
[Music]
while hearing tasty Steve and WWE's
Zelena Vega in an official Street
Fighter game is super cool the
excitement those commentators generate
during an actual tournament isn't ever
captured here those experiences are
fueled by genuine off-the-cuff reactions
to the action on the screen and in the
arena while those same voices sound like
they're reading situations from a script
here which of course is exactly what
they are doing Thrills to get around
their defense if you're looking for a
less traditional Street Fighter
experience then what's offered in
fighting ground it's time to take a
world tour this is a massive story mode
with multiple chapters that unfolds
across the entire world the main Hub is
Metro city of final fight Fame and it's
stuffed with things to do and references
for long-time Capcom fighting fans to
find the rest of the mode is broken up
into smaller locations based on stages
from the core game these are one of
locels you'll visit sparingly so they're
not as big as Metro City but as they all
still have a charm to them the story
being told in World Tour doesn't live up
to the standards set by fighting games
like Tekken 7 and more by 11. however
everything happening around the story
makes up for in a big way Walter is
essentially a street fighter RPG where
the fighting mechanics serve as the
battle system and it is very silly fun
walking through the streets of Metro
City I can challenge virtually anyone I
want to a fight be they a food truck
attendant an old lady going to the store
or a young Troublemaker getting up to no
good with every victory in my avatar
gains experience and levels up both
their core stats and the fighting styles
I'm using at the time this challenge
anyone mechanic is also technically
impressive as it really does let players
challenge anyone the game seamlessly
goes from challenging a passerby into a
fight and then returning to the free
realm without loading the stage is
whatever we were standing in front of at
that moment there is a noticeable dip in
frame rate when fighting in World Tour
and the visual quality of the stages and
random Fighters is nowhere near as good
looking as Ryu fighting Ken on a
carefully crafted stage but I didn't
focus on them much as I was too busy
enjoying the silliness of fighting every
Metro City Denizen that passed me by or
using money to buy a hat that somehow
improves my kicking power leveling up
fighting styles is the other major
customization option and growth path
your Avatar's move set is in your hands
and as you progress through the story of
Walter you meet the 18 masters of the
world aka the playable roster of Street
Fighter characters after earning their
respect through Mission completion or
even a one-on-one fight your avatar will
be enrolled as a student and given
access to that character's moveset
you'll pick a core move set for normals
but then you can pick and choose which
special moves you want your character to
use at one point my avatar used DJ's
rolling sober blank as Blanca ball
chunley spinning bird kick and Ken Shri
yukin that versatility and ability to
create your own fighter down to the
moveset is something new for the
franchise and a core part of what makes
World Tour fun using a fight stick to
control the Avatar in this mode is rough
the camera controls do not translate to
a controller with only one stick so
getting around the city can be
cumbersome the game does offer a
solution though it's not an elegant one
you can activate your fight stick as
player 1 and your controller as player 2
and then switch between the two
depending on if you're moving around
Metro City or fighting someone while
this does mean extra space is needed for
two controls at once I appreciate the
convenience of easily switching every
time I want to use it your avatar also
takes center stage in the battle Hub
which is the final section of Street
Fighter 6's experience this is basically
a middle ground between World Tour and
fighting ground where players bring
their avatars into a massive Dome lined
with arcade cabinets you can sit down at
a cabinet and wait for a challenger
while training or you can join a queue
of players already seated the digital
equivalent of putting a quarter down on
a machine through fighter 6 netcode
sings no matter who I'm fighting or
incredibly which server I'm logged into
I made sure to log into the North
America South America and Asia servers
during my review time and nearly every
match I played in all three felt like my
opponent was sitting in the room next to
me that's not to say it's perfect as
personal internet connections are also a
major factor in performance but the
Advent of rollback netcode has been a
major Boon to the entire fighting game
genre and 356 is the latest beneficiary
I had a couple of matches in the North
America region that did have some
netcode issues but my online play
experience as a whole has been
overwhelmingly positive fighting games
in the Modern Age live on through their
extra content and 356 is no exception
Capcom has not only confirmed the first
four characters coming via downloadable
content but much like 355 the game will
feature its own economy complete with
multiple currencies Drive tickets are
earned in game and fighter coins can be
earned in-game or purchased separately
as well as just as a battle pass which
will offer Avatar gear emotes and other
perks in both a free and premium track
given how strong the base game is having
more content and being able to play the
game in different ways is an exciting
prospect I can't get enough of 356 it's
been my last thought when I go to bed
and my first thought when I wake up in
the morning it has a beautifully
constructed fighting system but also
offers modes that take the game very
seriously and in other cases not
seriously at all there are some small
issues with performance in World Tour
but none of those are enough to derive
Builder overall package with the
releases of new Tekken and more combat
games it very much feels like we're in a
new golden era for the fighting game
genre thankfully Street Fighter 6 steps
into the arena looking good and fighting
fit
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
course that begs the question if he's a
man Mama then where might our true and
recently Empress Nadine's life is in
your hands sir praise be for only the
sovereign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
that is
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
Zelda it's one of Nintendo's most
prolific franchises you got your Mario
and you got your Zelda boom that's a
Nintendo I mean if you walk up to some
Rando on the street and ask them do you
know A tingle they're gonna say yes
because it was on America's Most Wanted
last week but did you know at one point
Zelda was on the brink of failure this
is the story of how the Legend of Zelda
Twilight Princess saved the Zelda
franchise
[Music]
foreign
hit the Mean Streets of Nintendo back in
1977 he quickly Rose to internal stardom
after creating Donkey Kong out of unsold
arcade Machines of radar scope in 1981.
then came the famicom NES in the West
[Music]
with the Japanese release of the famicom
Miyamoto worked on two games that would
come to Define Nintendo devil world and
excitebike
but afterwards he would simultaneously
work on two little games at the same
time Super Mario Brothers released in
and The Legend of Zelda released in
1986.
[Music]
again he worked on these at the same
time which is insane to me these two
games were Mega successes for Nintendo
Super Mario Brothers sold around 3
million copies within four months in
Japan alone and became a system seller
and a huge reason the NES succeeded in
the west meanwhile The Legend of Zelda
sold 1 million units on its first day in
Japan alone and afterwards these two
games would become Nintendo's pair of
golden geese laying critically acclaimed
system sellers one after another in fact
we have a whole video about Zelda's
games and our excellently written
history of Zelda video by Lucy James so
fast forward to this
you got your Mario 64.
Zelda Ocarina of Time
these two games defined and set the
stage for 3D games to comment in all of
gaming while Zelda was back and forth
one of Nintendo's largest properties
Ocarina of Time absolutely blew the
other games out of the water as the
fourth best-selling game of all time on
the N64 with 7.6 million copies sold
we're talking about a game that wasn't
only fantastic as one of the few 10 out
of 10 meme games of all time but a
trendsetter Ocarina of times lock on Z
targeting is still used to this day it
defined and still continues to Define
how to handle action in a 3D space and
Majora's Mask in our opinion
was weird as and seriously one of
my favorite Zelda games so the stage and
hype was set for Nintendo's next system
the Nintendo GameCube everybody and I
mean everybody was looking forward to
what new Mario game was coming and what
new Zelda game was coming then
spaceworld 2000.
foreign
[Applause]
consumers were looking for a brand new
super mature Zelda with ultra realistic
graphics at least realistic compared to
you know
this but the thing is while Western
audiences loved it ejawanoma hated it
mainly reviews of manly reviews what are
you doing here oh I have a green screen
nothing's real
by the way manly did an amazing video on
the same topic and if you haven't seen
it
you should so agnuma took one look at
the sick battle between link and
Ganondorf and Zed
nah this is a Zelda this isn't Zelda at
all and instead of this
he gave us this
[Music]
there's a long-running perception that
this was miyamoto's favorite version of
link as he always wanted Zelda to be a
cartoon that's a lie Miyamoto hated Toon
Link when he had to present the game
against his will he told alanoma that it
wasn't too late to make the graphics
realistic regardless of if you think the
game's amazing or not which it was by
the way reception in the West
um not so good after witnessing the cool
more mature version of the hero of time
Western audiences were not stoked when
they instead saw this Leapfrog version
of link that looked like he belonged in
Coco melon
this is a disgrace to the Zelda
franchise I wanted mature and I got
five-year-olds why why why this is
disgusting I have never seen a game
I just hope this is a cruel joke but it
doesn't matter what I think what matters
is what Nintendo thought even though the
GameCube itself underperformed according
to agnuma Zelda's numbers were
incredibly disappointing in Japan while
the New Direction hadn't appealed as
many people in the west which was now
becoming a Marcus Zelda would rely upon
so the team thought about what the issue
was and decided it was
Innovation sure
okay clearly if they made an Innovative
Zelda game with a brand new style of
gameplay they'd be able to reel back in
Japanese players so the solution was
clear two castles baby
what that's a terrible idea the game was
four Swords Adventures a follow-up to an
offshoot game bundled with the Legend of
Zelda A Link to the Past GBA port and
all players had to do to play as main
multiplayer feature was own a GameCube
and one Game Boy Advance per player as
each one would serve as a controller
yeah it didn't do well
I mean look the scores were fine but in
terms of sales we're talking less than
400 000 copies sold for a Legend of
Zelda game less than 400
000. later that year Capcom released the
Legend of Zelda the Minish Cap a more
traditional Zelda Adventure that sold
pretty well at 1.76 million copies but
really not much better than Metroid
Fusion which sold 1.6 million copies and
I'm sure you all know how rarely Metro
games have released since Metroid Fusion
and Prime 3.
so the question is was Zelda on the same
downward trajectory as Metroid Pokemon
Smash Brothers Mario Kart Mario and now
even sometimes Kirby we're starting to
outsell Zelda games with Zelda no longer
Nintendo's Golden Goose so EJ allenoma
decided to swallow his pride in Wind
Waker 2 baby what no not at all why
would you think that AJ alanoma decided
to shake things up he went back to the
realistic Graphics from the original
GameCube presentation but on a horse
all right
behind the scenes our Newman knew they
needed to try the more mature looking
link to relate to an older teen Western
demographic and Miyamoto didn't feel
like that was enough of a change for a
new Zelda he told the team they should
focus on horseback riding so four months
later the team had a very basic
prototype of horseback riding working
and dropped a surprise trailer at E3
2004 which garnered the prior reaction
and it was announced for fall of the
following year but there was one problem
there was no game notice how the trailer
has no subtitle it's just the Legend of
Zelda so it was time to hunker down and
decide what the hell this game was gonna
be on the positive front that standing
ovation and incredible reaction to the
trailer served as a huge motivation for
the team as they were excited by the
overwhelming response however they had
to come up with something new so the
team thought about how prior Zelda games
had alternate worlds light and dark and
linked to the past past and future in
Ocarina and decided to use this as
motivation what if they took link as a
rabbit from the Dark World and linked to
the past but made it cool what if they
made link a wolf Miyamoto
wasn't confident with the direction
where at the very least he didn't think
creating a four-legged creature would
work convincingly enough either way
inspired by Minish Cap which was also
then in development using a similar
mechanic with its big and small worlds
aegianuma and the Zelda team forged
forwards E3 2005 came a brand new
trailer and they decided on a title
Zelda TP
toilet paper
[Music]
but by E3 2005 just months before the
planned launch date how Numa wasn't
happy with the gameplay Innovations and
they still needed something major sure
fans were waiting three hours in line to
play it at 83 but to AO Numa the game
wasn't unique or good enough luckily
behind the scenes Nintendo was working
on something huge something
revolutionary the Nintendo Revolution
later known as the Nintendo Wii and
Miyamoto approached aunuma about
utilizing the new motion controller for
Zelda he thought this would be the
perfect Innovation to make Twilight
Princess stand out and unique from the
previous entries then satoru Iwata
wanted to push the game back to ensure
it was a masterpiece and told the team
they made something that was 120 Zelda
whatever that means it was decided to
push back Twilight princess's release
date by year to make the game available
for both the Nintendo Wii as a launch
title and available for the GameCube at
the same time and the team got to work
incorporating their game into the
Nintendo Wii which they thought would
help in the Japanese Market especially
first they used the remote which could
point at the screen for shooting Link's
bow next they made us a link would swing
his sword when players swung the remote
because most players are right-handed
they flipped the entire game and
mirrored it on the Wii so link who's
usually left-handed would be
right-handed and the Nintendo Wii launch
came
so fall 2006 there I was little Dave
waiting outside of my local game store
overnight for my copy of a Nintendo Wii
and The Legend of Zelda Twilight
Princess and so too were three out of
every four people waiting in line for a
Wii in fact 87 percent of people who
purchased the Nintendo Wii at launch
also purchased the Legend of Zelda
Twilight Princess it went on to be so
successful that became the best-selling
Zelda title in the series until breath
of the wild even outselling Ocarina of
Time whereas Ocarina of Time sold 7.6
million copies Twilight Princess sold
8.85 million copies and for asiao Numa
it was a personal success as it was the
first game he'd ever made that his wife
both wanted to play and finished which
she did with her son
hey Marissa will you play Twilight
Princess with me no
but going back to the sales you can see
just how Stark of a contrast Twilight
Princess was for the team while it still
didn't sell as well as Mario Kart Mario
or smash it was still the highest
selling Zelda game ever and solidified
once again that Zelda was a franchise
worth putting the time and money into
it's easy to think Nintendo can do
whatever they want especially with the
franchise as popular Zelda but I want to
take a look quote from then president of
Nintendo satoru Iwata in a conversation
with Shigeru Miyamoto and aegian Numa
Upon finishing Twilight Princess satoru
iwara says and I quote even with all the
resources we have here at Nintendo we
could only make something like this once
every few years in fact it might not be
easy to do something like this again so
I really want everyone to have a
wonderful time playing this game but
after the success of Twilight Princess
the next major game in the franchise The
Legend of Zelda Skyward Sword went on to
receive a five-year development time and
in a regularly High budget from Nintendo
I don't think Zelda would have
completely died if Twilight Princess
wasn't successful but like Metroid
f-zero and Pikmin I do think the
trajectory this series would have
changed and we would have perhaps seen
fewer zeldas or less time in budget
allotted to Future games and who knows
without it we might have never gotten
Skyward Sword as we did or more
importantly the team may have never
gotten the chance and time to make
breath of the wild today Zelda is bigger
than ever and that's all thanks to the
Legend of Zelda toilet paper thank you
so much for watching Once Again a huge
thank you to manly reviews for coming on
this episode I highly highly recommend
his own video on Twilight Princess as I
really personally love it and his
presentation style is incredible I know
I'm one of the few people who think this
but I'd actually rather replay Twilight
Princess than Ocarina of Time and look I
I know that Twilight Princess is like
the same game in a lot of ways but to me
it's a better Ocarina uh anyways I hope
you enjoyed this if you did please go
back and check out our episodes on Sonic
and Resident Evil 4 and next week we've
got an episode coming up on the Nintendo
switch
[Music]
it is time
to wake up
to a new reality
to a blank canvas that I have painted in
with warmth
peace
in my new era
choice is yours
whether to live in quiet serenity
or bloody strife
to dwell in joyous prosperity
or bitter rivalry
[Music]
you can face each other
as sworn enemies
or United as brothers
but a storm is brewing
and soon you will discover
even in this new era
one constant remains
there is always something worth fighting
for
you have chosen to defy peace then you
have chosen war with a god
oh
[Music]
Trump
[Applause]
ETS
foreign
[Music]
PlayStation
foreign
[Music]
leave Connor alone
to hunt I'll give him one he'll never
forget
who's gonna wish he never came to New
York
triangulating position
Target located at Harlem Fish Market all
teams converge lizards across the river
I'm not gonna make it in time
[Music]
miles the hunters tracked Connors to the
Harlem fish market
dessert
I'm on it sounds like Craven's checking
off his we don't have much time move
uh guess we'll chat later
Genki the lizard's loose at the fish
market must be Sushi night you still got
the hunter drone you hijacked and really
tough hiding it for my mom but yeah I'll
boot up and see you there
they got here fast
[Music]
can't let him find Connors or he's done
for it
[Music]
spread out if you find them isn't don't
engage
[Music]
fish
it's been feeding
we ever saw it coming
[Music]
huh
so how's the hunt going watch out there
by the three tons of dead fish not well
where are you Connors
garage my Lee tomb
Connor's tore through this place
is out of control
[Music]
where am I now
how'd you find me fell as a fish
drones picking up lizards Trail
he's still eating we can catch him off
guard
Yankee get behind me
it's just his skin
doesn't that mean he's getting bigger
[Music]
hungrier too
hey man any threats the building's
swarming with Hunters any sign of
Connors uh yeah Yankees tracking him hey
Mr Parker
mister
I mean
but the date isn't complete
that wasn't me me neither
I don't even have a stomach so
let's go
go go make him alive
can't lose counters Harry's dying and
he's the only one who can help we won't
you take the Drone I got the jet skis
well if I borrow this
this is really really exciting keep it
tight man watch out for those drones
don't worry they think I'm a friendly
chairs
East River is not a river but in fact
the saltwater title flat Spiderman is
fighting on right now
running down
help the tour boat right I've got the
metal murder bird
I warned you about going after Connor's
now this is on you
poison clouds that all you got
almost done here civilians are all safe
how are you looking
gunship won't quit I'm right behind you
we'll take it down together no time
I got you time to go boom boys no no no
Spider-Man it's good defenses
Spider-Man hang on
move
[Music]
come on let's go
it's right behind you I know I know whoa
Steve master
there
I do not want to be lizard food
okay
hold on
everyone take cover
what are you guys doing trying to take
out that gunship can't get close enough
but I can't I'm one of them remember bro
that's it hey alley-oop on three punch
one two three Ally
he got away from us
it's good Pete
I saved the tracker
let's go man before he gets too far no
it's fine
you sure
it's got big teeth
so do I
[Music]
um
he's not normally like that right
no
he's never like that
on Wheels build the perform better and
look cooler take raising them new
heights jump stunt crash now the fun
begins
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
I right to escape
every word is a step forward
[Music]
Into Darkness
I'm glad you're on this case with me
Anderson
it's right up your alley
the victim was one of their own
FBI special agent Robert Nightingale
so you knew our victim only the rumors
he was chasing a writer
someone knew they were here was playing
a game with them
killer left the message
it's for us
the text is about us
we were all trapped in a horror story
though our story wanted us dead
[Music]
there's something I'm forgetting
something important
something's not right
easy now
first things first what's your name
foreign
[Music]
I've never really considered myself much
of a collector but then one game came
along and basically changed all of it
it's a Japanese survival horror game
from 1999 for the Sega Dreamcast and
it's called D2 and it's responsible for
two things my obsession with collecting
other Japanese called horror games and
learning that retro games in Japan are
so damn cheap do a search on eBay for D2
and you will see just how expensive that
game can go for the Japanese version on
the other hand goes for just mere
dollars and it ain't just D2 whether
it's the Clock Tower series Echo Knight
ill bleed enemy zero you name it there's
always one consistent thing the American
ones are stupid expensive when the
Japanese ones are just ridiculously
cheap the thing is I became absolutely
consumed in trying to understand this
ridiculous price Gap and I think there's
a few
to explain it and what better way to
kick this all off than going to the
source
[Music]
foreign
I'm Kurt and I have never been to Japan
until today
this was my first time here and I was
completely alone and while I was here to
work in my downtime my agenda was simple
wander aimlessly eat and of course go
shopping for video games and where
better to start than Japan's electronic
District Akihabara games were everywhere
and I mean like everywhere there was
bins just out on the streets filled with
video games and when I did finally walk
into a video game store it had only been
a matter of minutes until I found
everything I had been obsessing over and
yes they were by American Standards
incredibly cheap not to mention a lot of
these games were complete in their box
and sealed D2 was right next to Seaman
and oh there was also a copy of D's
Diner on the 3DO seal and yes I bought
foreign
from this experience just being able to
walk into one store after the other and
see a multitude of these games of course
the first and most obvious speculation
was mass production these games were
made for a Japanese audience they are
likely to be more popular in Japan
therefore more copies of them were made
than they were in North America which is
a totally reasonable thing to speculate
but there is something else that stood
out to me while I was there that wasn't
just mass production the culture of
physical media
so considering the amount of shops I've
been in so far including the bookstore
that is aimlessly wandered into this
store felt like it had thousands of
movies
DVDs to choose from and when I realized
it was rental something that was
basically extinct in the states it made
me start thinking about this entire idea
of why games could be cheaper a little
differently here whether it's consoles
toppled on top of each other or endless
rows of games and movies it didn't feel
novel or like something to be coveted
they sort of felt meaningless but not in
a way that like they don't matter but
rather just how I'm used to seeing games
treated here in the states which are
often like collectors items in fact the
closest thing we're feeling I can relate
it to actually is second hand bookstores
walking through game stores in Japan is
a stark contrast to what it feels like
to walk into a game store in America it
felt more like I was rummaging through
places like this it's the same feeling
it's a place filled with hundreds of
books from classics to obscure ones most
of which you can buy for a few bucks
Just Books upon books stacked on top of
each other or found in bins on the
street like games in Japan the value
isn't in what the price tag says it's
what's in the pages it's what's in the
case which ties back to exactly what
sent me down this rabbit hole in the
first place
[Music]
I didn't want D2 because it was a
collector's item or because it was
expensive I wanted it because I have an
infatuation with its writer director and
composer Kenji Ina every game this dude
has made is off kilter and
unconventional in its design and D2 was
no exception it was also his last major
game that he wrote directed and composed
before he died in 2013. on the back of
the case of D2 it says a terrifying
Adventure unlike anything ever
experienced and you know what it is
absolutely right its pacing is slow and
brooding its horror as Brash and intense
and yet the combat is almost arcading it
is a hodgepodge of ideas and while it
may not work for everyone it certainly
landed with me because like the back of
the case says I will likely never play a
game like this from AAA Studio from a
major publisher ever again and it was
these experiences that got me excited
over the idea of collecting new and
weird and wacky things the value you in
me owning it was as sort of like a
symbol or an Ode to an artist that I
deeply respected and in turn it also
inspired me to want to find more games
like it that were often older Japanese
and extremely expensive and aside from
being expensive all the games I've
mentioned have one other specific thing
in common they're apparently like not
that good and you know what
I don't care
[Music]
being in Japan for a short time and
being able to get that first hand
experience of how easy these games were
to track down it honestly kind of bummed
me out you would think there would be at
least one Retro Game Store in San
Francisco they exist just outside of the
city and if I want to go to one I'd have
to get in the car and drive for around
an hour to get to any of them and guess
what
this guy doesn't have a car when in
comparison games in Tokyo just seem to
be culturally infused nearly anywhere I
wandered in the city it didn't take long
to just find a store that sold games it
really gave me a chance to see just how
differently games seemed to be viewed
here because that's what has sunk in in
the states games are treated like
baseball cards like Collectibles like
flipped sneakers and I mean that
literally there's a flea market I go to
every single month and without fail
there are always vendors selling all
those things every single time I go in
some cases the sellers didn't entirely
know the value of what they were selling
they just knew that games were valuable
and that's where I keep coming back to
this juxtaposition the games found at
flea markets and these vacant parking
lots that are just astronomically
expensive by my standards versus the
games I found on the streets of Tokyo
that look like they've been kicked
around and for a fraction of the price
and specifically I'm kind of referring
to that sun bleach copy of Super Mario
64. something that can be bought by
someone for just a few bucks and
cherished the same exact way I cherish
some of my favorite books that look like
they've been ran over and kicked on the
street 600 times both of which the game
and the books I'm referring to have
probably been played or read sold and
rebought a dozen times now putting
cultural reasons aside why we're in the
situation we're in concerning the prices
of games really stems from the game
grading bubble that inflated in 2021
when wada games a Grading Company sold a
copy of Super Mario Brothers for 2
million dollars and when that happened
despite game grading being a whole beast
in of itself the public eye saw a
headline that saw a game that sold for
two million dollars and therefore the
general public view of games was that
they were valuable that they were
expensive alongside comic books and
beanie babies and coins or whatever else
p people decide to collect which is how
we end up with people selling box Sega
Saturns at flea markets for six hundred
dollars when in comparison when I was in
Japan every single game store I walked
into had walls made of consoles for sale
that were at affordable prices I'm
pretty sure I saw like a Dreamcast for
like 40 bucks also it was only days
before I started searching to purchase
D2 which means that Super Mario Brothers
copy sold and then I just was like I
just want my weird little game and
that's of course of course when the
price skyrocketed and a good way to
actually like visually see how all this
happened as a site called
pricecharting.com which accumulates all
the sold versions of a game and then you
can actually see the actual chart of
when these games skyrocketed in price in
all that being set aside it's not like
I'm trying to say it's worth going to
Japan just because games are so much
cheaper to buy instead this whole thing
gave me the opportunity to reflect on my
relationship with collecting and why I
even collect in the first place for
every single person there's going to be
a very specific likely intimate reason
as to why they collect the things they
collect that could be for Nostalgia that
could be for preserving the medium it
could even be a sign of their identity
how they even represent themselves as a
person in my case I collect a lot of
things I collect either to honor a
specific artist because that thing had
some sort of influence on who I am or
you know I just like to preserve those
lost gems that I think are culturally
interesting even though you know
if there's one thing I can at least
confirm is that Japan just does not have
a retro gaming bubble like the one we do
but all of this
that's just my perspective
you let me know
[Music]
foreign
Has Fallen its great Army decimated by
the legions of a deer the demon god
but one light still flickers in the
ever-growing Gloom the light of the dark
crusader
the radiance of monster with us
[Music]
this
it is Darkness threatens to desolate our
world
Ascend to Aureus my child
as His Holy Redeemer
in light we walk in lights we walk
burn
[Music]
Souls
your flesh has been made sacrosanct with
the mark of the dark Crusaders
[Music]
thank you
great potential dwells within your
doubtless for you to be chosen firstly
[Music]
foreign
prove yourself worthy of this gift
[Music]
by your Radiance grant me the strength
to continue to endure these dark days
[Music]
another unfortunate made a slave to
unceasing hunger
I pity you
reignite the Blessed beacons of monstada
and thwart ideas cataclysmic
Resurrection
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
marches on
these people live with a knife to their
throat you have to believe us we'd help
you if we could
but you're helping us already
we never asked to be saved did you think
we'd thank you they'll never forgive us
we're all marked now
every time you show your faces it is we
who suffer
[Music]
he better hope so
crystals take more than they give you
need to tell me that the mother crystals
are the reason the world is dying
down we're talking is they won't give us
a say we'll decide our Fates another way
do you believe what I'm about to do is
wrong I was forced to kill you do it by
choice
do you believe in me they believe in the
powers of dominant you Can't Blame A man
for wanting to bring it into all this
can you ever let us Stray by your blind
results
we don't need your salvation we'll save
ourselves and we'll do it on our own
towns
who are we what are the dominance
of God enough of this I use my talents
to my advantage you would tell me there
is shame in that we we shared a dream I
would be the king of the world
Darkness has taken hold of you it has
made you forget yourself I don't want to
be a monster of life
something
I made a promise to my friends and it is
they who will give me the strength to
lend your Reign your efforts will Avail
us not
right
to survive we enjoy we don't need a
reason
[Music]
thank you
it's sometimes difficult to reconcile
that Diablo 3 is over a decade old its
release was polarizing for a number of
reasons but its evolving formula of
action role-playing endured enjoying a
Resurgence with his post-launch
expansion that carried through years of
ongoing seasonal updates it shouldn't
come as a surprise then that each of
those years helped to inform the design
of Diablo 4 a game which confidently
delivers gameplay that has been carried
forward and refined from Diablo 2 and 3.
while also establishing a strong
foundation for the franchise's future
foreign
games have always contained stories for
their single player campaigns but you'd
be forgiven for thinking of past
storylines as merely contextualization
for the game's primary focus dungeon
crawling that's where Diablo 4 makes one
of its most striking changes it not only
takes its story far more seriously but
it tells one that's far more engrossing
than ever before as a traveling Wanderer
you come across a small town of villages
on a snow-capped mountain range looking
for some Aid after killing some
creatures and returning you're welcomed
as a hero and given food and shelter
only for the villagers to try and use
you in a ritual sacrifice to Lilith
co-creator of sanctuary and recently
resurrected antagonists of this tale
this encounter links you to Lilith
driving you forward on a quest to stop
her plan of amassing an army for her own
nefarious purposes
by mother's blood
thy mother's body
so shall you witness her glory
before you die
much of that sounds like standard Diablo
Fair there's a big bad demon and you're
the only one who can stop it but Diablo
4 makes intelligent use of Lilith
layering her motivation slowly to the
point where you can't help but consider
her side of the argument she's not
driven solely by a Lust For Destruction
instead she's grieving with the place
she once created to escape the endless
cycle of War Between Heaven and Hell now
being used as a staging ground to
continue it she's an antagonist that has
been slighted by those she trusted at
every turn and while her means of
exacting Justice provide the reason for
your entire crusade in the first place
it's surprising and equally welcome when
Diablo 4 forces you to slow down and
consider the true goal of your struggle
not just any demon the daughter of
hatred the mother of sanctuary the trop
of the Soul Survivor has been tried and
tested in Diablo for years and Diablo 4
doesn't completely change that instead
it puts a much larger emphasis on
companions than ever before with most
acts centered around a new party member
rather than a demon you're eventually
hunting down an early standout is Vigo a
prideful Knight who is forced to endure
a conscious ruining loss after a single
selfish action it's not just vigo's
remorse that is heart-wrenchingly
conveyed but also the horrors of his
eventual Redemption leading to one of
the more powerful character moments in
the entire game vigo's story is a teaser
for many similar arcs that follow all of
which do a great job of providing a
cause for your character to join your
fight while also contextualizing their
motivations to continue or abstain from
the enduring conflict this applies to
most of the Allies you recruit in your
fight against the lift Each of which has
their own motivations that feel faithful
to their respective Journeys it's a
level of care I can't recall being given
to many past Diablo Companions and
Diablo 4 certainly makes far more
liberal use of them through the campaign
to make them feel purposeful bringing
together this ragtag group takes place
over Diablo 4's extensive sex acts some
of which you can tackle in different
orders previous Diablo titles had each
Act accompanied by a change in Locale
but in Diablo 4 it only takes a few
moments before you're given free reign
to explore its intimidatingly large
interconnected map here you can
transition from frigid mountain tops to
desolate deserts in just a matter of
minutes with the transitional areas
doing a good job of masking an otherwise
jarring change having a static layout
that you can learn and get comfortable
with infused Exploration with a greater
sense of wonder than previous hubs which
were often filled with enemies to kill
before diving into the next dungeon the
geography also gives towns and larger
cities a sense of place on a bigger map
each distinct area is shown off of a
great amount of visual detail with
Diablo 4 incorporating a delightfully
Macabre style that is befitting of its
violent story it's not trying to overly
correct some of the criticisms laid on
Diablo 3 either with pops of color used
Tastefully to highlight areas of Hope
and kinship that contrast against the
broader Strokes of dread and fear
painting the rest of the landscape
things don't always hold up when the
camera Zooms in to give conversations a
cinematic feel as a degradation in
detail on character models and
environments is a little more
discernible regardless it's still a
striking presentation that looks
incredible in motion while also keeping
information clear enough to read when
fights get chaotic
the moment-to-moment action in Diablo 4
is one of its strongest traits which is
for the best given how genre defining
the series has been over the years
there's an argument to be made that
Diablo 3 went too far in the direction
of simplification and that's exactly
where Diablo 4 course corrects in smart
ways you're still limited to a total of
six Active abilities at a time four on
your Hotbar and two on each Mouse button
for those on PC but how you construct
your build is no longer linear instead
each new level lets you invest a point
in a branching skill tree with each of
its core notes branching further out
into new abilities and Associate passive
perks you need to invest a certain
number of total points that continue
unlocking each of these nodes so you
will have to think carefully about
abilities and how they serve your
greater build it's a system that allows
for a lot of flexibility letting you
experiment with focusing on one specific
ability as the foundation of your build
or dabbling with ways to combine two
entirely different paths such as
empowering your summon skeletons while
also firing off loads of blood infused
magic as a necromancer
okay
experimentation is further encouraged by
Diablo 4's low cost to respect and
unlimited chances to do so unlike the
more punishing approach on Diablo 2 you
can completely redefine your build at
any time for a small fee of in-game gold
approaching your skill tree with a
different idea or mindset or just making
some small changes to adjust for a
difficult fight this freedom is
empowering in a similar way to that of
Diablo 3's fluid build system but it
still requires you to engage
meaningfully with synergies to make your
builds viable it feels like the
culmination of all the ways previous
games in the series have allowed you to
play while catering to as many play
Styles as possible but without many of
the critical compromises from the last
time out the cost for respect does
naturally increase the higher level but
it never went to a point where I felt it
was too expensive in relation to the
amount of gold I was earning at the time
thanks to this system I felt free to
continually change up my approach to my
Necromancer I started with a combination
of skeleton summoning Shadow damaging
attacks and some blood spells for
survivability The Necromancer is unique
ability lets me either summon minions
from corpses or sacrifice the ability
entirely for Passive advantage Ages
which led me to realize that I could
theoretically play a necromancer
entirely as a pseudo Mage with Blood and
Bone abilities after some taxing boss
battles I decided to go all in on a
summoning build that accentuated the
abilities of my skeleton soldiers Mages
and large hulking Golem Each of which
had three different variations that
could combine to find the perfect
Synergy it was consistently satisfying
to find a build that worked for a couple
of hours and then completely change it
either through necessity or curiosity
seeing small decisions manifest as big
changes in terms of overall viability
gives me faith that each class is going
to be picked apart for various
approaches that maximize elements of
different play Styles while the skill
tree is where you will ultimately
establish the basis of your build
aspects of Power are a new facet of the
role-playing formula that allows you to
hone it these collectible skills so to
speak can be combined with rare pieces
of gear to turn them into custom
legendary items imbued with the exact
ability that complements the build
you're constructing this alleviates some
of the headaches associated with
grinding out dungeons in the hopes of a
particularly legendary piece of gear
dropping while also providing a new
Avenue of options for build construction
that isn't to say it diminishes the rush
of a big legendary drop though Legendary
Weapons can often feature the same
abilities as aspects do but will
regularly have better percentage roles
on their effectiveness making them the
ideal path to the most optimal late game
build still
aspects of Power are obtained by
clearing the many dungeons sprawl around
the map Each of which feature their own
multi-stage objective to complete some
are as simple as killing enemies and
depositing their souls to progress
further While others require you to hunt
down a specific foe in search of a key
that lets you reach lower levels of the
dungeon each of these concludes with a
boss fight which for the most part are
less interesting than those found in the
main story dungeons bosses throughout
the story are multi-layered bouts with
shifting enemy attacks that can
completely change the landscape you're
fighting in forcing you to consistently
think about positioning and when the
best moment for an attack is bosses in
these more common dungeons lack that
sense of complexity and I often found
masculine Warriors completely
overwhelming many of them to the point
where many of the bosses would just
stand in place and attack until dead
thank you
given the sheer number of dungeons on
offer it might not have been possible to
retain the same level of tension across
every boss encounter but when you're
bouncing between several of these as you
grab aspects of power throughout your
campaign it's difficult not to notice
the Stark contrasting quality between
the two as with any Diablo title Diablo
4 is nowhere near complete once you've
rolled credits on the campaign volte's
return to incentivize you to go through
everything again with a high degree of
difficulty but also more rewards to reap
it's welcomed that Diablo 4 retains the
option that allows you to jump into more
challenging World tiers from the very
start this time preventing a potentially
frustrating first playthrough devoid of
any meaningful challenge outside of
increasing world here the map becomes
littered with additional side activities
that join regular side quests rotating
open mode Dynamic quests similar to the
Patrols in Destiny 2 and strongholds
strongholds are extremely hostile areas
that are densely populated with enemies
usually a level or two higher than you
providing a larger challenge to overcome
than regular groups or foes around the
open world minor objectives also make
this feel like a smaller scale open-air
dungeon with new waypoints and Merchants
usually locked once you've read the area
of the threat
[Music]
larger scale World boss fights that are
best tackled with numerous other players
you will find in the open world are also
available although no multiplayer
features were available during the
review period finally Whispers of the
Dead encapsulate time bounties that pop
up throughout the world with each one
rewarding you with an additional
currency that can be turned in for
caches of gems weapons and More Night
messages which can be obtained through
completing Whispers of the Dead quests
can be used to unlock additional
nightmare dungeons these add new
modifiers to existing dungeons around
the map that can do anything from change
the type of enemies you encounter to
Rolling new random abilities they might
have at their disposal with the Allure
of even rarer loot drops enticing you to
run them over and over again
there's a familiar but equally expensive
framework in place already in Diablo 4
that should satiate you across multiple
playthroughs with plans already detailed
by a blizzard to expand on this through
seasons of new content similar to that
of Diablo 3. now our true work begins
Diablo 4 at this time cannot Escape
comparison to the past of the franchise
it belongs to but it's thankfully a game
that has been crafted with a strong
awareness of what made each one either
revered or reviled it represents a
measured approach to combining the many
elements from previous entries that
worked into a system that feels like the
new standard Bearer for Action
role-playing coupled with a new
Benchmark for storytelling in the
franchise and a solid narrative
foundation for any potential new
adventures it's easy to see Diablo 4 as
something I'll regularly check out for a
long time to come
[Music]
it unlocks our path to the Future
a future made possible because of the
price you paid
[Music]
your sacrifice
will not have been in vain
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
mirror
I'll let you taste the power of like
this
foreign
[Music]
what's your status
we're coming to you now
they're plotting something what motive
do these creatures have to attack this
facility these are mere drones then what
guides them a worthy adversary
you will pay you what a currency
officerate this abomination
delta wing report the spores collapse
the bridge there's no way through get
into assault position by the bridge
smart hospitality
come forth and be slaughtered
[Music]
foreign
welcome
hidden one
[Music]
you have died and been Reborn
foreign
[Music]
we need to find a way to get you inside
without being seen
you could bribe the guards to look the
other way I shall see what flavor best
suits me
[Music]
embrace the fear
quiet it find a Stillness
and let's go
thank you the stage is your spasm
we will be watching
[Music]
what's his name
he can hear you
he's always listening
[Music]
last night I dreamed that my uncle hung
himself in the Attic that we were too
late
[Music]
it was still called or setup
definitely a weird place feels like I've
been here before and I just can't think
why let's not waste any time detective
yeah me right let's go get your uncle
Miss Heartwood
[Music]
he's always trying to create a mystery
right something that's more than just
jump scares
a bit of fighting demanding puzzers and
a lot of atmosphere
that maintain some of that weirdness of
the old games but it had like an updated
slickness to it that I liked as well you
haven't seen a little girl by any chance
have you I don't think so yeah you would
have known if you did
we start our story much like the
original Jeremy Hartwood is haunted by
the dark man and he goes to a
Countryside Hospital called just set up
and hope to find some help
I need to get this letter to my niece
she would understand
Jeremy sends a disturbing letter to
Emily Hartford his niece and it Spooks
her enough that she hires detective
Edward carmby to find out what's going
on who are you whoa pardon me excuse me
my name is Edward cornby Pride
investigator I hope you don't mind we
let ourselves inside I do mind we knew
early on that we had a character driven
story so we needed to find some really
good actors to make those characters
come to life
I knew of past iterations of the game I
mean the Video Game World is something
that I'm very interested in in general
the horror game genre specifically
David has a really strong presence as an
actor and he's able to make the funny
moments really funny but also the
dramatic Parts really intense why the
hell do I wake up hearing that damn
voice
[Music]
Gruff Detective and he's like searching
for something and you know he's uh he's
hard-boiled but he's got some humor to
him and stuff like that he's a bit of a
Trope or a type and I like that and I
like the world and sort of how he's
exploring this Insanity
um amidst all this horror and stuff I
liked all those aspects let me know if
you find her I'll be around
[Music]
Emily Heartwood has a closer connection
to the plot as she is Jeremy's needs
nifra also suffers this strange
Affliction known as the hardwood cross I
love the mystery of the game
um I love the picture of her like there
was so much about it that I was curious
of
there's a lot of fear within her and a
lot of speculation and curiosity and
um I guess
dread Intrigue like there's a lot of
belt hair that is
um kind of on edge
10 years now
more even since he died
he died a hero
Jody's a fantastic actress and she
brings a lot of nuance to Emily as a
character and it really makes us
sympathize with them
who's in here
Show Yourself yes there is the the kind
of scary element but then she still has
to go on a journey and discover
different things and they should still
be room to breathe and have a funny
moment or a sarcastic moment or a moment
of Discovery
um so it's just trying to really kind of
keep all those other beats alive amongst
the
um the kind of Darkness of it all I
guess is how I felt anyway
so we're bringing back both Emily and
Edward as the playable characters and
depending on who you play you will get a
different take on the same story
the people that you said it will react
differently to you depending on who you
play
even the story will be slightly
different what are you doing sneaking
around so you should definitely make
sure to play the game twice
oh
the way that we reimentioned the game
was basically looking at the original
and it feels like we've been cultivating
a seed that was planted 30 years ago and
it has now grown into something even
more dark even more sinister
I remember that with the first alone in
the dock I met in 1992 we were basically
doing something that nobody had done
before it was the first time that we
could explore a big mansion fight
monsters and solve difficult puzzle all
in real time Swedish
[Music]
at the chorus at haunted mansion that's
the most important part it's dorsetto I
would say
feeling that you're entrapped inside
kind of small space yeah I used to say
back in the old days that it was another
character yeah for sure
with all the remakes going on today you
are never sure what you get at the end
I think that Mikhail and the team at PCS
did a great job preserving the core
feeling of the game they even went
further than everything I could expect
30 years ago it's really an honor to
sort of be a part of the franchise in
that sense because it is such a again I
it can't be overstated it's so special
it was such a new experience
as a fan of the original I wanted to
bring as much as I could into our
version and they might have a slightly
different meaning and different reasons
to be there but if you know the old
games you will find a ton of references
do I know you from somewhere
I remember you Mr convey
I feel the franchise is in good hands
now and I can't wait to play the full
game
[Music]
to give you a taste of what the full
game will be we also created a prologue
and it features a character from the
game called Grace Saunders at least a
little girl and you play as her walking
around your Seto and trying to post a
letter
[Music]
the prologue is the first glimpse into
the atmosphere in the mood and of course
the story of the full game so if you
want to have a look go and download it
right now
so crazy
[Music]
our combo is intense and tough and you
will need to use every bullet you can
find and if you run on bullets I'm out
of bullets you might need to get in
close
or if you're lucky you can find
something to throw
as mentioned before your job is to find
out what happened to Jeremy hardwood and
to do that you will need to visit some
unexpected places
and to get to those places you'll need
to find Clues and solve some interesting
process
depending how much you feel like a
detective yourself you can choose how
much you want the game to help you find
Clues and where to go next
so the biggest creative around your
setup and trying to post a letter
[Music]
the prologue is the first glimpse into
the atmosphere in the mood and of course
the story of the full game so if you
want to have a look go and download it
right now
oh
[Music]
crazy
our combat is intense and tough and you
will need to use every bullet you can
find and if you run on bullets I'm out
of bullets you might need to get in
close
[Music]
or if you're lucky you can find
something to throw
as mentioned before your job is to find
out what happened to Jeremy hardwood and
to do that you will need to visit some
unexpected places and to get to those
places you'll need to find Clues and
solve some interesting process
depending how much you feel like a
detective yourself you can choose how
much you want the game to help you find
Clues and where to go next
so the biggest creative Focus for me as
for long time being to reach something
beyond the mundane
something spiritual
Mike the director and I we spend a lot
of time trying to figure out what
direction musical direction we want to
take in this project and
we finally decided to
go for this kind of dark we're doing
Jazz Direction our minds went directly
to Jason who is a master in this genre
it's a very visual genre of music the
fact that it's inspired from noir films
or Noir detectives is already a good
explanation of why this music fits very
well for um along in the dark
huge mountain and volcano of of Reverb
with drums and screaming saxophones
[Music]
to this explosion of hair Rising horror
and and
big chaos
as the players drawn deeper into the
game World they will face off with the
Sinister presence known as The Darkness
real Jeremy there's nothing you can do
to hurt you how do you think any of this
is happening how do you still not trust
more words
fine then let me help be foolish he will
bury you next to me in his sunken Temple
for an eternity
real or not something is definitely
corrupting the mind of Jeremy something
very very dangerous
[Music]
thank you
356 has learned lessons from the content
Bear release of its predecessor and
offers a variety of significant features
and modes right out of the gate it's a
robust fighting game that is a premier
quality a return to form for the
franchise that welcomes both new
Fighters and seasoned Pros
356 splits this content into three hubs
fighting ground which most closely
emulates the classic street fight
experience battle Hub where players can
congregate and challenge each other to
compete in tournaments and World Tour
which is a sprawling story mode with an
open world and RPG hooks each gameplay
format centers on the classic Street
Fighter style of 2D fighting gameplay
and that excellent core experience is
what drives everything
mechanically Street Fighter 6 doesn't
fall far from previous games in the
series you have multiple normal attacks
special attacks super arts and movement
techniques specifically designed for
each of the roster's 18 characters what
distinguishes street fighter 6 from
previous iterations are the core
Universal mechanics shared by all
characters these Universal mechanics are
also where much of street fighters
gameplay depth is the drive system is
Street Fighter 6's new Universal battle
mechanic and I'm amazed at how much it
adds despite being simple to grasp by
pressing the two medium attack buttons I
can Parry an attack using Drive Parry or
with Drive rush I can immediately Dash
forward out of it for a burst of speed
that can catch opponents off guard or
introduce new combo sequences
off the face
functionally players that are
experienced with three fighter 4's Focus
attack Dash cancel all kyoti gears Roman
cancels will feel right at home by
pressing both heavy attacks I can
initiate a drive impact that can stagger
an opponent and leave them open ensuring
that overly defensive players can be
opened up if an opponent is back into a
corner Landing this will make him Bounce
Off the Wall adding a variety of other
strategic considerations and
opportunities Drive reversals meanwhile
allow me to block an attack and counter
with a move that while not very damaging
will help Escape tricky spots and
finally overdrive lets me power up
special attacks like the EX system of
old
these aren't unlimited however as each
move uses up part of the drive gauge
just below the health bar and a fighter
can burn out which slows their movement
speed and makes certain offensive and
defensive moves inaccessible for a
period the Strategic implications of
this system cannot be overstayed as
these new tools do wonders for the
overall fighting drive impact in
particular can swing the tide of the
battle in an instant as catching an
unsuspecting opponent with one will
allow you to put a hurting on them
keeping these tools in front of your
mind is key to Victory and luckily it's
not an overwhelming amount to recall one
of the major criticisms leveled at s355
was the rigidity of battles with some
going so far as to call it turn based
however these new mechanics make stream
fighter 6 feel more fluid
no matter how simple Street Fighters can
seem novice players are going to feel
some trepidation when stepping into the
ring for the first time the game is
ready for you though as Capcom has
implemented a new modern control scheme
that makes controlling Fighters more
like Super Smash Bros than a traditional
Street Fighter this gives new players a
foundation from which to learn but that
growth does have a ceiling if you decide
to transition to the classic control
scheme players will need to learn the
manual input controls that have been
used since Street Fighter 2. the easiest
place to learn 356 either in modern or
classic Styles is in fighting ground
which is a traditional street fight
experience this is where you'll find
familiar modes like arcade mode online
ranked and Casual matches and offline
versus modes this section's shining
feature however is its practice area
which houses some of the best in-game
tutorials the series has ever had
practice mode has the classic freeform
training mode fans expect but also holds
full tutorials for the game's core
systems as well as character guides and
combo trials for all 18 characters on
the roster these character guides are a
deep dive into what makes each fight a
tick as it explains not only their
special moves but also the best
situations in which to use them fighting
ground also lets you Tinker with in-game
commentators one of the more balihood
features of Street Fighter 6.
[Music]
foreign
while hearing tasty Steve and WWE Zelena
Vega in an official Street Fighter game
is super cool the excitement those
commentators generate during an actual
tournament isn't ever captured here
those experiences are fueled by genuine
off-the-cuff reactions to the action on
the screen and in the arena while those
same voices sound like they're reading
situations from a script here which of
course is exactly what they are doing
Thrills to get around their defense if
you're looking for a less traditional
Street Fighter experience then what's
offered in fighting ground it's time to
take a world tour this is a massive
story mode with multiple chapters that
unfolds across the entire world the main
Hub is Metro city of final fight Fame
and it's tough with things to do and
references for long-time Capcom fighting
fans to find the rest of the mode is
broken up into smaller locations based
on stages from the core game these are
one of locales you'll visit sparingly so
they're not as big as Metro City but
they all still have a charm to them the
story being told in World Tour doesn't
live up to the standard set by fighting
games like Tekken 7 and more combat 11.
however everything happening around the
story makes up for in a big way walto is
essentially a street fighter RPG where
the fighting mechanics serve as the
battle system and it is very silly fun
walking through the streets of Metro
City I can challenge virtually anyone I
want to a fight be they a food truck
attendant an old lady going to the store
or a young Troublemaker getting up to no
good with every victory in my avatar
gains experience and levels up both
their core stats and the fighting styles
I'm using at the time this challenge
anyone mechanic is also technically
impressive as it really does let players
challenge anyone the game seamlessly
goes from challenging a passerby into a
fight and then returning to the free
realm without loading the stage is
whatever we were standing in front of at
that moment there is a noticeable dip in
frame rate when fighting in World Tour
and the visual quality of the stages and
random Fighters is nowhere near as good
looking as Ryu fighting Ken on a
carefully crafted stage but I didn't
focus on them much as I was too busy
enjoying the silliness of fighting every
Metro City Denizen that passed me by or
using money to to buy a hat that somehow
improves my kicking power leveling up
fighting styles is the other major
customization option and growth path
your Avatar's moveset is in your hands
and as you progress through the story of
Walter you meet the 18 masters of the
world aka the playable roster of Street
Fighter characters after earning their
respect through Mission completion or
even a one-on-one fight your avatar will
be enrolled as a student and given
access to that character's moveset
you'll pick a core move set for normals
but then you can pick and choose which
special moves you want your character to
use at one point my avatar used DJ's
rolling sober blank as Blanca ball
chunley spinning bird kick and Ken Shri
yukin that versatility and ability to
create your own fighter down to the
moveset is something new for the
franchise and a core part of what makes
World Tour fun using a fight stick to
control the Avatar in this mode is rough
the camera controls do not translate to
a controller with only one stick so
getting around the city can be
cumbersome the game does offer a
solution though it's not an elegant one
you can activate your fight stick as
Player 1 and your controller as player 2
and then switch between the two
depending on if you're moving around
Metro City or fighting someone while
this does mean extra space is needed for
two controls at once I appreciate the
convenience of easily switching every
time I want to use it your avatar also
takes center stage in the battle Hub
which is the final section of Street
Fighter 6's experience this is basically
a middle ground between World Tour and
fighting ground where players bring
their avatars into a massive Dome lined
with arcade cabinets you can sit down at
a cabinet and wait for a challenger
while training or you can join a queue
of players already seated the digital
equivalent of putting a quarter down on
a machine through fighter 6 netcode
sings no matter who I'm fighting or
incredibly which server I'm logged into
I made sure to log into the North
America South America and Asia servers
during my review time and nearly every
match I played in all three felt like my
opponent was sitting in the room next to
me that's not to say it's perfect as
personal internet connections are also a
major factor in performance but the
Advent of rollback netcode has been a
major Boon to the entire fighting game
genre and 35 is the latest beneficiary I
had a couple of matches in the North
America region that did have some
netcode issues but my online play
experience as a whole has been
overwhelmingly positive fighting games
in the Modern Age live on through their
extra content and 356 is no exception
Capcom has not only confirmed the first
four characters coming via downloadable
content but much like 355 the game will
feature its own economy complete with
multiple currencies Drive tickets are
earned in game and fighter coins can be
earned in-game or purchased separately
as well as just as a battle pass which
will offer Avatar gear emotes and other
perks in both a free and premium track
given how strong the base game is having
more content and being able to play the
game in different ways is an exciting
prospect I can't get enough of 356 it's
been my last thought when I go to bed
and my first thought when I wake up in
the morning it has a beautifully
constructed fighting system but also
offers modes that take the game very
seriously and in other cases not
seriously at all there are some small
issues with performance in World Tour
but none of those are enough to derail
the overall package with the releases of
new Tekken and more combat games it very
much feels like we're in a new golden
era for the fighting game genre
thankfully Street Fighter 6 steps into
the arena looking good and fighting fit
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
force that begs the question if he's a
man Mama then where might our true a
recently Empress Nadine's life is in
your hands sir
for only the sovereign
[Music]
[Applause]
PlayStation
[Music]
thank you
foreign
Zelda it's one of Nintendo's most
prolific franchises you got your Mario
and you got your Zelda boom that's a
Nintendo I mean if you walk up to some
Rando on the street and ask them do you
know A tingle they're gonna say yes
because it was on America's Most Wanted
last week but did you know at one point
Zelda was on the brink of failure this
is the story of how the Legend of Zelda
Twilight Princess saved the Zelda
franchise
[Music]
foreign
hit the Mean Streets of Nintendo back in
1977 he quickly Rose to internal stardom
after creating Donkey Kong out of unsold
arcade Machines of radar scope in 1981.
then came the famicom NES in the West
[Music]
with the Japanese release at the famicom
Miyamoto worked on two games that would
come to Define Nintendo devil world and
excitebike
but afterwards he would simultaneously
work on two little games at the same
time Super Mario Brothers released in
and The Legend of Zelda released in 1986
[Music]
again he worked on these at the same
time which is insane to me these two
games were Mega successes for Nintendo
Super Mario Brothers sold around 3
million copies within four months in
Japan alone and became a system seller
and a huge reason the NES succeeded in
the west meanwhile The Legend of Zelda
sold 1 million units on its first day in
Japan alone and afterwards these two
games would become Nintendo's pair of
golden geese laying critically acclaimed
system sellers one after another in fact
we have a whole video about Zelda's
games and our excellently written
history of Zelda video by Lucy James so
fast forward to this
you got your Mario 64.
got your Zelda Ocarina of Time
[Music]
two games defined and set the stage for
3D games to comment in all of gaming
while Zelda was back and forth one of
Nintendo's largest properties Ocarina of
Time absolutely blew the other games out
of the water as the fourth best-selling
game of all time on the N64 with 7.6
million copies sold we're talking about
a game that wasn't only fantastic as one
of the few 10 out of 10 meme games of
all time but a trendsetter Ocarina of
time's lock on Z targeting is still used
to this day it defined and still
continues to Define how to handle action
in a 3D space and Majora's Mask in our
opinion
and seriously one of my favorite Zelda
games so the stage and hype was set for
Nintendo's next system the Nintendo
GameCube everybody and I mean everybody
was looking forward to what new Mario
game was coming and what new Zelda game
was coming then spaceworld 2000
this this was what western consumers
were looking for a brand new super
mature Zelda with ultra realistic
Graphics at least realistic compared to
you know
this but the thing is while Western
audiences loved it ejawanoma hated it
mainly reviews of manly reviews what are
you doing here oh I have a green screen
nothing's real
by the way manly did an amazing video on
the same topic and if you haven't seen
it
you should so agnuma took one look at
the sick battle between link and
Ganondorf and Zed
nah this is a Zelda this isn't Zelda at
all and instead of this
he gave us this
[Music]
there's a long running perception that
this was miyamoto's favorite version of
link as he always wanted Zelda to be a
cartoon that's a lie Miyamoto hated Toon
Link when he had to present the game
against his will he told awanoma that it
wasn't too late to make the graphics
realistic regardless if you think the
game's amazing or not which it was by
the way reception in the West
um not so good after witnessing the cool
more mature version of the hero of time
Western audiences were not stoked when
they instead saw this Leapfrog version
of link that looked like he belonged in
Coco melon
this is a disgrace to the Zelda
franchise I wanted mature and I got
five-year-olds why why why this is
disgusting I have never seen this game
I just hope this is a cruel joke but it
doesn't matter what I think what matters
is what Nintendo thought even though the
GameCube itself underperformed according
to agnuma Zelda's numbers were
incredibly disappointing in Japan while
the New Direction hadn't appealed as
many people in the west which was now
becoming a Marcus Zelda would rely upon
so the team thought about what the issue
was and decided it was
innovation sure okay clearly if they
made an Innovative Zelda game with a
brand new style of gameplay they'd be
able to reel back in Japanese players so
the solution was clear two
castles baby what that's a terrible idea
the game was four Swords Adventures a
follow-up to an offshoot game bundled
with the Legend of Zelda A Link to the
Past GBA port and all players had to do
to play as main multiplayer feature was
own a GameCube and one Game Boy Advance
per player as each one would serve as a
controller yeah it didn't do well I mean
look the scores were fine but in terms
of sales we're talking less than 400 000
copies sold for a Legend of Zelda game
less than 400
000. later that year Capcom released the
Legend of Zelda the Minish Cap a more
traditional Zelda Adventure that sold
pretty well at 1.76 million copies but
really not much better than Metroid
Fusion which sold 1.6 million copies and
I'm sure you all know how rarely Metro
games have released since Metroid Fusion
and Prime 3.
so the question is was Zelda on the same
downward trajectory as Metroid Pokemon
Smash Brothers Mario Kart Mario and now
even sometimes Kirby we're starting to
outsell Zelda games with Zelda no longer
Nintendo's Golden Goose so EJ allenoma
decided to swallow his pride in Wind
Waker 2 baby what no not at all why
would you think that AJ aoinoma decided
to shake things up he went back to the
realistic Graphics in the original
GameCube presentation but on a horse
oh
behind the scenes how Newman knew they
needed to try the more mature looking
link to relate to an older teen Western
demographic and Miyamoto didn't feel
like that was enough of a change for a
new Zelda he told the team they should
focus on horseback riding so four months
later the team had a very basic
prototype of horseback riding working
and dropped a surprise trailer at E3
2004 which garnered the prior reaction
and it was announced for fall of the
following year but there was one problem
there was no game notice how the trailer
has no subtitle it's just the Legend of
Zelda so it was time to hunker down and
decide what the hell this game was gonna
be on the positive front that standing
ovation and incredible reaction to the
trailer served as a huge motivation for
the team as they were excited by the
overwhelming response however they had
to come up with something new so the
team thought about how prior Zelda games
had alternate worlds light and dark and
linked to the past past and future in
Ocarina and decided to use this as
motivation what if they took link as a
rabbit from the Dark World and linked to
the past but made it cool what if they
made link a wolf Miyamoto
wasn't confident with the direction or
at the very least he didn't think
creating a four-legged creature would
work convincingly enough either way
inspired by Minish Cap which was also
done in development using a similar
mechanic with its big and small worlds
aegonuma and the Zelda team forged
forwards E3 2005 came a brand new
trailer and they decided on a title
Zelda TP
toilet paper
[Music]
but by E3 2005 just months before the
planned launch date how Numa wasn't
happy with the gameplay Innovations and
they still needed something major sure
fans were waiting three hours in line to
play it at E3 but to AO Numa the game
wasn't unique or good enough luckily
behind the scenes Nintendo was working
on something huge something
revolutionary the Nintendo Revolution
later known as the Nintendo Wii and
Miyamoto approached anuma about
utilizing the new motion controller for
Zelda he thought this would be the
perfect Innovation to make Twilight
Princess stand out and unique from the
previous entries then satoru Iwata
wanted to push the game back to ensure
it was a masterpiece and told the team
to make something that was 120 Zelda
whatever that means it was decided to
push back Twilight princess's release
date by year to make the game available
for both the Nintendo Wii as a launch
title and available for the GameCube at
the same time and the team got to work
incorporating their game into the
Nintendo Wii which they thought would
help in the Japanese Market especially
first they used the remote which could
point at the screen for shooting Link's
bow next they made it so link would
swing his sword when players swung the
remote because most players are
right-handed they flipped the entire
game and mirrored it on the Wii so link
who's usually left-handed would be
right-handed and the Nintendo Wii launch
came
so fall 2006 there I was little Dave
waiting outside of my local game store
overnight for my copy of a Nintendo Wii
and The Legend of Zelda Twilight
Princess and so too were three out of
every four people waiting in line for a
Wii in fact 87 percent of people who
purchased the Nintendo Wii at launch
also purchased the Legend of Zelda
Twilight Princess it went on to be so
successful that became the best-selling
Zelda title in the series until breath
of the wild even outselling Ocarina of
Time whereas Ocarina of Time sold 7.6
million copies Twilight Princess sold
8.85 million copies and for asiao Numa
it was a personal success as it was the
first game he'd ever made that his wife
both wanted to play and finished what
she did with her son
hey Marissa will you play Twilight
Princess with me no
but going back to the sales you can see
just how Stark of a contrast Twilight
Princess was for the team while it still
didn't sell as well as Mario Kart Mario
or smash it was still the highest
selling Zelda game ever and solidified
once again that Zelda was a franchise
worth putting the time and money into
it's easy to think Nintendo can do
whatever they want especially with the
franchise as popular Zelda but I want to
take a look at a quote from then
president of Nintendo satoru Iwata in a
conversation with Shigeru Miyamoto and
ajia Numa Upon finishing Twilight
Princess satoru Iwata says and I quote
even with all the resources we have here
at Nintendo we could only make something
like this once every few years in fact
it might not be easy to do something
like this again so I really want
everyone to have a wonderful time
playing this game but after the success
of Twilight Princess the next major game
in the franchise The Legend of Zelda
Skyward Sword went on to receive a
five-year development time and in a
regularly High budget from Nintendo
I don't think Zelda would have
completely died if Twilight Princess
wasn't successful but like Metroid
f-zero and Pikmin I do think the
trajectory this series would have
changed and we would have perhaps seen
fewer zeldas or less time in budget
allotted to Future games and who knows
without it we might have never gotten
Skyward Sword as we did or more
importantly the team may have never
gotten the chance and time to make
breath of the wild today Zelda is bigger
than ever and that's all thanks to the
Legend of Zelda toilet paper thank you
so much for watching Once Again a huge
thank you to manly reviews for coming on
this episode I highly highly recommend
his own video on Twilight Princess as I
really personally love it and his
presentation style is incredible I know
I'm one of the few people who think this
but I'd actually rather replay Twilight
Princess than Ocarina of Time and look I
I know that Twilight Princess is like
the same game in a lot of ways but to me
it's a better Ocarina uh anyways I hope
you enjoyed this if you did please go
back and check out our episodes on Sonic
and Resident Evil 4 and next week we've
got an episode coming up on the Nintendo
switch
foreign
[Music]
time to wake up
to a new reality
to a blank canvas that I have painted in
with warmth
in my new era
choice is yours
whether to live in quiet serenity
or bloody strife
to dwell in joyous prosperity
[Music]
or bitter rivalry
you can face each other
as sworn enemies
or United as brothers
but her storm is brewing
and soon you will discover
even in this new era
one constant remains
there is always something worth fighting
for
you have chosen to defy peace
then you have chosen war with a god
thank you
[Music]
Trump
[Applause]
ETS
foreign
[Music]
PlayStation
foreign
[Music]
Connor's alone
to hunt I'll give him one he'll never
forget
he's gonna wish he never came to New
York
triangulating positions
Target located at Harlem Fish Market all
teams converge lizards across the river
I'm not gonna make it in time
[Music]
miles the hunters tracked Connors to the
Harlem Fish Market blizzard I'm on it
sounds like Craven's checking off his we
don't have much time move
uh guess we'll chat later
Genki the lizard's loose at the fish
market must be Sushi night you still got
the hunter drone you hijacked and really
tough hiding it for my mom but yeah I'll
boot up and see you there
they got here fast
drop it down can't let him find Connors
or he's done for it
[Music]
spread out
find the message don't engage alone
[Music]
there's fish it's been feeding
we ever saw it coming
[Music]
laughs
so how's the hunt going
by the three tons of dead fish not well
where are you Connors
garage my lead to him
Connor's tour through this place
out of control
[Music]
where am I now
how'd you find me fell as a fish
drones picking up lizards Trail
he's still eating we can catch him off
guard
Yankee get behind me
it's just his skin
doesn't that mean he's getting bigger
[Music]
hungry or two
hello everyone and welcome to game
Sports pre-show for summer game Fest
2023 I'm Lucy James and joining me
Davina
hi hi and tomorrow it's summer game Fest
baby summer game game
fast yeah I died I refuse
no someone says I'm a games Fest I'm
like there's I feel it is but it makes
me think there's only one game that
everyone everyone is celebrating it is
The Game of Life of E3 it is yeah it is
the game Fest is a a long game that
Keely is playing with the esa yes in
like taking them over becoming he's like
the Symbiote takes over Eddie Brock it
really is the long game yeah it's like
that's the game that we're playing here
we're all players in this game I respect
it singular game well during the summer
yeah we've wrote that that intro as far
as worth of stuff back to back reveals
some hopeful World premieres World
premiere more than one game more than
one more than one game
um and allegedly Keely says we've got
three to four things that are going to
be pretty big for this audience and
actually physically big
yes oh because it's actually happening
at the YouTube theater yeah about 3 000
people in the audience allegedly
um we are doing it from here and our
lovely little there are of course 3 000
people watching us too yes hello to the
audience yes
people are sitting in their seats
before I was talking about physically
there's three thousand people yeah no
it's like oh yes look it looks like very
quiet thank you thank you guys they're
being polite but let's talk about
day uh and maybe some some wishful
thinking about what we hope we can see
let's kick off with the thing that I
think Jeff has been teasing the most
which is um the gameplay reveal of
Mortal Kombat one yeah specifically Ed
Boon's so I'm not
I am not right law
now this is Mortal Kombat One One
spoilers for Mortal Kombat 11.
Liu Kang is basically a God now okay so
he's he has the ability to reset
universes right he had it and in his
Brave New World
this is the first Mortal Kombat that
takes place so he's recreated the world
I believe that's the case right now I'm
trying to avoid spoilers because
apparently I care about Mortal Combat
fiction way more than I realized I mean
those
those the stories of those games are
they're banging that's what I that's
what I hope that we get to see a healthy
amount of we've got a decent amount of
it in the original reveal trailer which
is good like we get to see
um like Shang Tsung is back and he's up
to no good it feels very much like a
reboot of the franchise and it is like
they're rebooting it within the fiction
of the the game itself which is a very
much A Realm Reborn type approach to it
um so Liu Kang is there he's kind of
remade everywhere out of the world and
he's given it seems like he's given
everyone an element of free uh rain and
control over their Destiny so I think
the whole thing is going to be like how
does the Mortal Kombat sides the lines
get drawn a second or third whatever
maybe time is you know is Kung Lao still
a good guy when when the crap hits the
fan is you know Shang Tsung really a bad
guy again so it's a really interesting
way to kind of remix stuff that we know
and play with Nostalgia but also have it
happen with the Modern Age of
um Mortal Kombat where the characters
are the ones that we know the tricky
thing is the story up until this point
has involved involved
going back to all the Mortal Kombat
games so we've got like older versions
of new characters existing alongside
these new versions of all it's going to
be wild which is typical more combat
yeah yeah I just like I was just gonna
say like because when it was revealed it
was more combat one because we're like
what is going on what is the deal with
Mortal Kombat uh I mean if you had
played Mortal Kombat 11 it's like the
only Direction they could have gone
story wise yeah and I know like you know
people may be playing as solely as a
fighting game rather than story driven
game
um but like I think the I have opinions
about it as a fighting game oh yeah but
as a story fighting game it's great and
like the the the 11 was like
a time traveling you know like they that
the entire you know the basis of that
game and its DLC was about time travel
so it only makes sense to restart and I
also think it's at a good point to
restart
going back on Nostalgia maybe also the
movie just came out I enjoyed the big
hit just came out it came out a while
ago look yeah
absolutely
I just look okay there is another one in
production obviously with uh called
Urban to be playing Johnny Cage and that
kind of stuff so just as mine he didn't
he just didn't have a play uh Kano or
whatever uh the yeah I guess so Kano
would make sense given his origin but I
also kind of like him as New Zealand
yeah yeah my kennel is vaguely
Australian oh well I guess I don't
remember they actually got so they can
they can like double up on that but uh
yeah I think he would have been good as
like he's good in pretty much he could
be cabal he just just have him play
dread yeah I mean yeah dread sequel yeah
so you think it's going to be Gameplay
trailer and stuff today I think it's
going to be a gameplay Focus no you
sorry you said uh like most story stuff
Keely said the Boon is gonna blow the
roof off the YouTube theater I'm
thinking we're gonna get
I feel like at this point if you're
showing off a Mortal Kombat trailer and
presenting it as it's gonna blow the
roof off the the kind of like it's going
to be incredible just like gameplay
story and brutal fatalities isn't enough
to be like this is going to be a big
deal because that's always What Mortal
Kombat has been I think the thing that
is going to blow the roof off you know
the event and the the venue is guest
character announcements
I've already had some leaks yeah so
we've had some leaks um I think
there has to be some X Factor that we
don't know about
um and I imagine one if there's anything
that I had to put my money on it's a
unexpected guest character
um that uh that people are surprised to
see that really sticks with is what Jeff
and Ed might be hinging of course it
could be just like oh my god look how
brutally this person is being
eviscerated by you know scorpions I mean
yeah I guess like to blow the roof off
you are right because it's an
expectation that we're just going to see
violence and fatalities and gameplay
also the game's coming out this year
correct yep
[Laughter]
wow wow
that's a that's a violent uh I have no
idea what it composite with the big Big
Boon boom could be for today so and
Boone in the game
well isn't it he's a isn't um isn't it
he's his character like the was this the
new example no um
noob I literally just said Noob I think
oh he's a noob cyborg sorry cyborg yeah
no no what are you talking about it's
new I'm going to move us along for
Mortal Kombat uh because there are a
bunch of other games that we know are
going to be in the Showcase today
including lies of P which uh you played
a big chunk of at GDC earlier this year
um what were your impressions of it what
do you think I'm gonna see today I think
it was um
really interesting I I think it's got a
lot of potential based on what I played
of it the combat I my memory isn't great
but like I remember thinking this feels
pretty good it just needs some like
tweaks here and there and some
rebalancing remember that donkey fight
there's that one fight yeah
one fight this guy like he's wearing
like a donkey mask and perfect yeah and
obviously it was freaky but um also like
it felt slightly on which is about which
is fine it felt slightly unbalanced and
a bit too like severely punishing oh
interesting which is like I'm all for
that I love sales games but this felt
like this I like I do like those guys
um but it felt like it was like off but
it's like the the punishment is super
harsh for slight errors in in kind of
like strategy but
um yeah I like the the atmos what was
important was like the atmosphere was
good the world was interesting I didn't
get to read a lot of the law or anything
like that but being in that space where
I was like oh I want to see what else is
going on with this Pinocchio game which
is crazy to think about it's it's based
on Pinocchio
um but yeah so far I think I like what I
see and I'm quite harsh towards Souls
like games
um not harsh as in like unfairly harsh
but it really I struggle to be impressed
by all I get excited about souls like
games that aren't like from software
stuff like there's very few that I would
be like oh this is a this is one I
recommend to other people like Neo is
probably one of them but everything else
is kind of like you tried but you're
missing the magic I feel like this has
some of the magic I'm just excited to
see more um I think they'll probably
show off a decent chunk of it again
um it's been a while since we've seen it
and I know that it's got a lot of
interest and kind of momentum behind it
so I think this would be a good
opportunity for them to show off an
extensive look at the game and you know
yeah the thing that piques my interest
when they showed it again was that uh it
was like because the trailer was very
story driven it was a very cinematic
which is you know like not usually
something we see with
Souls game Souls likes where it's like
there's an emphasis on this like um cut
scenes and like these kind of like sort
of big action sequences so uh having no
idea what lies a p is other than like oh
is that bloodborne looking game with a
rope with the with the ticker with a
ticker toy of men and the donkey head
guy
um I was I'm interested to see that if
if it is taking a more like deliberate
cinematic story driven approach
um there may be some other if it's
counterparts yeah that is a
distinguishing factor a lot of you know
from games aren't very cut scene heavy
and they you have to work to get that
story so if they can do okay decent or
good gameplay experience that also has a
more directly told story with cut scenes
and characters that you if you you can't
miss basically in the same way that you
can in other Souls that games that could
be the distinguishing factor for them
that gives them a bit of a leg up and
also sales as a kind of entry point to
to the genre so
I'm intrigued I'm intriguing to see more
about it uh one that's definitely got my
interest uh Immortals of avian we're
getting uh more gameplay there was a
Hands-On recently a bunch of people went
to play it it is the brand new game from
ascendant Studios it's being published
by EA under the EA Originals label it's
kind of ticking all of my boxes in terms
of sci-fi stuff magic fantasy looks
really I don't know like in terms of
performance capture and stuff they've
got
um uh Gina Torres in there they've got
um oh the guy who played if you ever
watched never have I ever uh the main
love interest from that Netflix show
um I'm Andrew Wyatt it looked I think in
the in the trailers we've seen from it
so far it's been very
fast-paced which can be a good thing but
also had a little bit of ghostwire Tokyo
about it with um well yeah that's like
that's always the thing when you see a
game like that at least for me it's like
it just needs to feel like I'm yeah
shooting something I want to understand
what I'm doing rather than quick cut
Quick Cuts in Ghost Fire Tokyo like I
remember just feeling so like I'm just
like this character's just like waving
their hands around screen and stuff's
happening
um it looks cool it doesn't feel great
it doesn't feel great for me but that's
like the thing with this game that's
like if because it's all isn't it
there's it's like all magic hand
shooting and stuff yeah finger guns yeah
if it was figure guns only like actual
finger guns someone must have made a
first person
isn't it like a Call of Duty like like
uh there is a I think it's included as a
goof or in in some shoe oh no
development
yeah we've made we're copywriting or
like yeah the game it's finger guns
perfect
um uh so we're gonna see gameplay of
Immortals of abium yeah uh speaking of
Call of Duty we're gonna get some war
zone season four
yeah but also like what can you really
like I feel like this Warzone has
reached a point where it's successful
but in becoming a good success it's just
the low hum of it exists and there's not
really a exciting announcement that you
can make around it Beyond we're having a
new season you know rumors abound of
things like modern warfare three yeah I
feel like that's time for the new yeah I
feel like that's the kind of like thing
that you use to elevate a war zone kind
of reveal it's like oh this is laying
the groundwork for the next Call of Duty
game but I don't know if you do that
within something that you directly
promote as Warzone
um maybe it's like oh we've got an event
coming up in this season you know
Captain Price is back and now he's a
cyborg
um but yeah Call of Duty black fans love
it obviously like Amazon is persisting
in a in a like healthy way but it's just
like if you play Warzone you probably
know everything that's happening in
Warzone and you're not surprised by
what's happening in Warzone and if you
don't play Warzone you're just like cool
that's whatever you're talking about for
you uh similarly in terms of live
service games we're getting updated
we're getting a look at fortnite's Wilds
update the new brand new season
um
if you are keeping up to date with
fortnite you probably dissected that
trailer long ago yeah and you kind of
roughly know what to expect but we'll
get a look at it uh we're also gonna get
so I was looking at the tweet it says
like Henry Cavill and the cast of The
Witcher uh look it's season three part
one because God forbid Netflix would
make an entire season of something and
just release it as one in one go
um we're gonna get a look at the Witcher
3 The Witcher season three sadly not The
Witcher 3.
um
imagine imagine
uh did you guys keep up with The Witcher
Beyond Susan I'm not the one to look at
I feel like we've had three in a row
where I'm like cool yeah I'm so happy
for you cool cool
it's a big hit it's obviously going to
be interesting because Castle is
[Music]
getting the Hemsworth uh taken over yeah
I wonder if they work that into the
story somehow oh I imagine I I well like
I imagine you do but also like you do it
in a way where you say oh geralt's not
here anymore you kind of lose a big part
of kind of that world where you know if
James bonded yeah I mean like yeah I
think like
I I would prefer them to figure out some
sort of Doctor Who system where it's
like oh somehow Gerald is regenerating
regenerated
he looks slightly different
and he has to learn himself again yeah
yeah yeah so yeah he's it's just
grappling with whoever he's the best
Hemsworth constantly yeah
uh Matt Smith isn't what the Game of
Thrones won he's in House of the dragon
and he has one white hair he does yeah
this writes itself honestly uh so yeah
we're getting a richer trailer we're
also getting uh more Boulders gay threes
Boulders gay I am super excited for
Baldur's Gate I played it in Early
Access
which was 2020 when it first went in but
it is it's coming out uh I think it was
August General did they actually nail
down that release date I don't remember
but I'm super excited
I'm just
I'm also at the point now where I was
all in the first time I saw it and I
just have not been keeping up with any
of the new announcements because I was
they've already got me so what do you
think uh could excite you both today
let's give me a console release too
right yes like I mean that in itself is
like uh it's pretty fantastic yeah I
play original sin too on console
um I I only so I did play Boulder's Gate
3 until last year uh so I didn't get to
see it in this like Early Access form
and like where it started and where it
is but like it was fantastic like I
can't like it's just it's just I it's
one of those games I was like this can
be I can play this a hundred times in a
million different ways and like never
get sick of it so just if uh I can't I'm
sorry I can't confirm in my brain
history if it's if it's getting a
console release but that in of itself I
think it would be just I think that is
confirmed yeah and like I'm happy with
that we've all said it like it came out
it wasn't complete the Early Access
obviously it was the first time we
played it but
it was already in a great in great
shape and it was just a matter of
for me it was like okay I am confident
that this will get to a point where I'll
be interested in playing it start to
finish to some degree so I've done the
same thing where it's like I'm gonna let
you guys figure this out and once you're
ready like yeah and then I'll come back
and that's where we reached the point
now yeah that team just cares so much
about it or at least it feels like they
just care so much about what they're
making and so much about what they're
doing
um and I don't know it's just it'll be
good I guess like it's one thing to play
a game in Early Access and still be like
this is fantastic and play it as you
know a normal sort of game experience
whatever but it'll just that official
like it's out it's done it's released
here it is yeah it's out of early I
think go for it I'm just excited to be
able to sit down and like yeah you know
indulge in it knowing that it's like
this is it like this is what you're
doing I think we get a little more story
stuff this time like I feel like we're
not finished yeah that's that's the main
thing and now that they've reached the
kind of
final Milestone and put like a a point
in the timeline down for where they want
to hit they can also start talking about
the cool story stuff that they have come
up with recently and and kind of
integrated into it and then also they
love like every trailer they do they do
some wild like
Cosmic horror stuff to get people you
know um excited about that stuff so I
bet you we see some real freaks like in
in this trailer
um and then yeah and then yeah here's
the Arizona is out yeah enjoy uh
speaking of
expecting to see some real freaks some
freaky stuff oh yeah we know that Alan
Wake 2 Gameplay is uh gonna be on stage
Lovely Sam Lake will be there we were
chatting to him yesterday we don't know
what they're showing we're talking about
something else with Sam
um Alan Wake 2 I think amongst the three
of us is one of our most most
anticipated games of the Year big fans
of Alan
there's there's just like I'm so sorry
no I'm just excitement excited about it
there's there's like there's several
things like there's I'm a very specific
breed and brand of person who likes very
specific things so like out of principal
everyone Ellen week two has announced I
just felt like every like people didn't
even need to know whether or not I
played the first one they were just
we're like
uh and there's a lot of things I'm
hearing about this game that I just want
to uh punch myself in the face on uh on
on purpose
um in a good way yeah I'm just like I
just need this I want to knock myself
out into this out yeah yeah uh because
we know from some stuff that books from
interviews that we did with Team uh from
Gamespot like there's gonna be obviously
survival horror check that box yeah uh
it has to do with like dual worlds and
surrealism check that box nothing
checking makes that sound well you know
what it does in codes well have you have
you listened to my pen
is also a golf club
but uh there's also investigative
elements yes the new character is an FBI
profiler and as a big fan of stuff like
True Detective and mind Hunter I was
like hell yeah yeah
nice files I was gonna say X-Files Twin
Peaks yeah well that's easy I mean that
Sam even when we were talking about it
yesterday they were talking about stuff
like seven and I was like oh my God yeah
yeah we've got like extensive coverage
of
um Alan week 2 on the site like if you
want stuff about
he's been a full-time Alan Wake reporter
for the last two weeks yeah
um he interviewed Sam he interviewed um
I believe Kyle and maybe
as well and has done like extensive
stuff about the development of the game
the actual uh kind of story of the game
and also try to provide as much
information as he can around the lore
and context and that kind of Remedy
connection
Universe which is super important to
this game as well so I feel like we're
already in a good position to know about
Saga Anderson as the Dual protagonist I
think now we start to move towards like
broader stuff with how Allen's involved
and also how that kind of deal
protagonist works from a gameplay
standpoint we know that we can move
between them I think they show off a
little more of that now and we're
expecting gameplay so yeah we can see
there's a bit more of that there's just
so much Amigo about it because I think
remedy is on this really really
fascinating up swing like you know with
control being like you know really
planting them in like the the core of
their identity I think like really
kneeling what they were and what they do
and how they do what they do
um but like every the thing I'm most
fashioned about about is that each one
of their games in one way or another
um criticisms a side of Alan weeks the
original analy weeks combat has some
sort of like Innovative approach to how
they do their gameplay
um you know even like Alan Wake the
first game being 13 years old like
playing at that time it was like it just
feels great it's the you know it gets a
little repetitive but it feels it still
feels remarkable yeah and
um
I'm just interested to see how remedy a
studio that has like
really innovated its tech for each game
they make I'm so interested to see how
they were like how they're almost
so many of their games are so awkward
and their effects and their like their
action and I'm so interested to see how
they're going to be dialing themselves
back you know like they're not making an
action-focused game this time it's again
the first attempt at like not going over
the top and trying to like you know Pace
things slower and like those are things
like weirdly I'm so anxious to see a
studio a creative interesting Studio
like remedy attempt a genre like this a
genre that like I'm extremely very
intimate uh with so that's what I'm just
so anxious yeah it feels like survival
horror as a genre has kind of almost
codified and like figured out and it has
been for a really long time thanks to
stuff like Resident Evil and Silent Hill
and we generally most survival horror
games of that kind of scale don't come
out but also um if anyone's gonna figure
something new out with this genre is
high probability it's them you know yeah
uh I mean so Alan Wake I'm super excited
I think the thing for me with regards to
it being a survival horror is all about
the pacing I replayed the original Alan
wig which is an action game it's an
action game and I think you know in the
early hours the
it feels unfetical in a gimmick but you
know the kind of cool gameplay Loop of
you know making sure that they're lit up
and then and then yeah it does wear off
but even from the Gameplay trailer the
PlayStation showcase a couple weeks ago
already saw so much more variety talking
with Sam yesterday who was talking about
the fact that you know talk about pacing
how to think how to make it scary how to
keep it tense and all the while
interweaving this story because original
alawick a lot of questions yeah control
a lot of questions and now the fact
you've got this remedy connected
Universe I'm I don't want all of the
answers leave more questions give me
give me more questions uh so we know
we're going to see gameplay of that we
also have cyberpunk Phantom Liberty the
side Punk account tweeted those gonna be
Hands-On play days which is the kind of
pine closed doors media event we'll be
heading down to on uh tomorrow and
Saturday so make sure to check back to
Game Spot throughout the weekend because
we're gonna have a lot of Impressions
gameplay from everything we're gonna be
playing cyberpunk Phantom Liberty is the
expansion
starring Idris Elba it's meant to be
more of a Noir crime Thriller in night
City uh boys what are your what are your
opinions on cyberpunk in general are you
excited for Phantom Liberty oh yeah I'm
excited to see more of that
um
really interested to see where it goes
given how the main campaign ends and
where you can take it yeah I'm not sure
if this actually and I mean I assume
this takes place in the middle of
somewhere sort of like you know blood
and minded for whichever there was a
point in the story that you could go to
yeah and obviously I like Idris as a
kind of active within this universe I
mean like he has just put Luther in it
yeah in
um
I feel like he fits in really well here
like it makes a lot of sense to have
someone like him in this in the same way
that like you see Keanu when he appears
you're like oh I didn't expect that but
it makes perfect sense he would be a
great Johnny silverhand and it feels
like Idris is gonna fit in nicely and
this is gonna sound real weird but
the original cyberpunk I want to kiss
him in a lot I do want to kiss him
um original cyberpunk in a lot of ways
overshadowed by the issues that it had
um the thing that I'm most excited about
is cyberpunk now is quite different from
the cyberpunk that launched
um it's in a much better state I'm
excited to be able to go into that game
again and have more of a discussion
hopefully rejuvenate a discussion around
that whole experience now because if
that's good if we can get something on
the level of blood and wine it's gonna
like it's gonna Revitalize the community
in the same way that the Netflix series
is Edge Runner did and hopefully that
kind of reignites the community to come
back to it and figure it out and talk
about it a little more from a from a
narrative perspective
um the other thing is like is he going
to be there
I feel like
that moment where Keanu stepped out into
the crowd and just had this eruption
it's as much part of the cyberpunk
history as more so than any other like
marketing or prb has been for any other
game like yeah
I felt like he was so invested and also
Keanu has a different you know he's got
a different energy yeah there's a
different heir to him there's a
different you know association with him
I agree with that but if you're on the
CD product red team do you care about
that surely you're being like we we want
another Keanu like moment which do you
bring Idris out and you know he's like
100 bring it it's me I I 100 think
interest is going to be there uh we have
two minutes until showcase itself uh
it's gonna run for about two hours and
then we'll be back here after to break
down everything that we saw so let's
quickly go into rumors and predictions
Kurt what are you really hoping to see
today that we haven't talked about uh I
I uh what was your dream
Alan Wake three
um to be completely honest
I just want to see it on point two more
I like I don't really have much of a
prediction other than just I'm here to
absorb things uh like I feel like
there's already such a jam-packed list
of what we know we're gonna see I guess
and I guess most of the stuff that I'm
looking forward to seeing we'll probably
see in other showcases like Xbox like
when I think of the things I'm excited
about I think of like
one could dream that they're out of
nowhere just like hey wolf Wolfenstein 3
is finally actually going to be revealed
you know like that would be uh that
would be wonderful but again I don't
expect that today yeah so I just want to
see more in one week I just want to see
more remedy yeah no I think it'll be
interesting I think we might see quite a
few things that will be there that are
going to be elaborated on elsewhere so
like the thing I when I think about what
I want to see is like I want to see the
next part of Final Fantasy 7 remake but
is that likely to be here is that likely
to be squarely showcase squares oh
because of the impending release of 16.
I mean they they did that question and
answer thread that they're doing
constantly over the last few days and
one of them was like
you know it's very soon so we'll see
yeah yeah we're about to go there all
right you have your moment what do you
think shout it uh
uh you've said Wolfenstein and now it's
all I can think about yeah that's all we
should think about is outside three I
mean I don't think it's gonna be here
today I think it'll be if anywhere at
the Xbox Bethesda Starfield showcase we
are going to throw over to Jeff Keeley
enjoy the Showcase we'll be here
[Music]
thank you
foreign
the creator of the game awards Jeff
Keeley
[Applause]
hello everybody Welcome to summer game
fast
we are in person and today we've got a
look at what's next in video games for
you we are live here in Los Angeles at
YouTube theater and it feels so good to
be in person with a live fan audience
for the first time ever welcome
everybody
when I started summer game Fest back in
2020 from a spare bedroom I never
imagined it would grow into this today
the video game industry has come
together to show you what's next this is
a cross industry showcase meaning no
matter where you play games I hope
you'll discover a new game to put on
your wish list the landscape of video
game events has certainly changed over
the past few years but one thing hasn't
there are a lot of great games in
development and our singular goal today
is to get you excited about the future
in just a few minutes we'll see the
first extended gameplay of Mortal Kombat
one
it delivers don't worry Alan Wake two
the reveal of fortnite's next season
and yes
we do have a very special Grand Finale
that you're not gonna want to miss all
I'll say right now
but let's get right to the games and
gameplay the first reveal is something
you're not expecting which makes it that
much more exciting here we go
our kingdom is cursed
the prince has been kidnapped and taken
to a forbidden land
all hope rests with us the Immortals to
rescue him and save the empire
we weren't prepared for what was coming
next up so I can't say no
then again they weren't prepared for me
foreign
times of Darkness hope is the only thing
that keeps us fighting
I will fulfill my destiny and save the
kingdom
[Applause]
there's a little surprise Prince of
Persia the Lost Crown is coming in
January 2024 a brand new
action-adventure platformer in the
iconic series with deep combat some huge
boss fights and of course incredible
platforming puzzles and animation
bringing a modern take on the legendary
franchise you'll be able to see more at
Ubisoft forward streaming on Monday as
part of Summer game Fest all right let's
move along to another iconic video game
franchise that just celebrated 30 years
that's right
it's time for Mortal Kombat one
couldn't keep you waiting on this one
[Applause]
it has been four years since MK 11 and
ever since Ed Boone the team at
netherrealm have been hard at work on
the most ambitious MK yet that reboots
the series into a New Era timeline and
it's coming this September everyone has
been asking what does it look like who's
on the roster how do the new Cameo
Fighters work well now it is time for
combat no spoilers but this video is
literally insane here is an extended
First Look At The Story gameplay and yes
of course the fatalities
of Mortal Kombat one let's do it
[Applause]
[Music]
I have had enough of you then go before
I put you down
today you have proven worthy of joining
us come there are other Champions I must
gather
what do you want Bento it's my family
blade cento's mine and I won't give it
up without a fight
foreign
okay let's go back to one here
who are you again Lord Liu Kang
protector of Earth rail
god of fire
you have skills Raiden but you're
inexperienced whatever experience I lack
I make up for in harm
if your disease becomes known you will
be banished I only want what's best for
you or do you secretly covet my throne
foreign
[Music]
come here
[Applause]
I mean that was pretty good right guys
now I'm sure you have many questions
about what we just saw and to tell you
more I am so honored to welcome to
summer game Fest one of our industry's
greatest creators a man who has been
loyal to the same franchise and fan base
for more than three decades please join
me in welcoming to summer game Fest the
creator of Mortal Kombat Ed Boone
[Applause]
[Music]
congratulations
they love you all right well Ed uh first
of all thank you for that incredible uh
World premiere we got to see all the
gameplay of MK1 and everyone just wants
to know more about this because first of
all this is in a it's MK1 right we went
from 11 to one so tell us about this is
it a new timeline yeah yeah um I don't
know how many people have seen the the
ending of Mortal Kombat 11 Liu Kang
basically was kind of graduated into
like you know a fire god right and he's
he created a brand new universe and this
universe this is why we're calling it
Mortal Kombat one is because this is the
beginning of a new timeline a number of
these characters you've seen before but
they're told in a completely different
story and so Sub-Zero and Scorpion are
brothers now and there's there's all
these things that were rivalries before
are now allies and so mixing the whole
thing up so we're just kind of rebooting
and that's what the one is for well it
looks incredible everything we saw there
was you know in game gameplay the
cinematics look incredible I know the
team has been working for four years on
this but the thing we gotta talk about
are these cameos because we saw some
pretty amazing stuff there now tell us
how does that work you obviously you
have your sort of your main you know
character that you'll pick and then I
know you also have a separate kind of
Cameo menu so you pick sort of a pair
when you start the game yeah normally in
in a fighting game you'll you'll see a a
roster basically you know where you
select your character after you do that
there's a second roster of characters
which are a whole new uh completely
different Fighters that are the Cameo
Fighters and these Fighters actually
they will join the fight but not the
blank squares there yes so it's kind of
like imagine yourself with sub-zero but
you have some of Jack's moves and you
can call him out you can do it multiple
times as you saw in the gameplay you
know so you can piece you can basically
combine these two characters all the
characters can be combined with all the
Cameo Fighters and that's where you see
that's where the players kind of
imagination comes in and they can
actually customize it for what they like
seeing you know the best team ups well
so how does that work so you're in game
gameplay you have your main you have
your cameo how do you do you summon them
is it time base like how often do they
come into it's not a tag team thing
right yeah yeah exactly and and you're
you're basically summoning them it's
just one button pushes basically
summoning but they have a variety so you
can go you know push that button with
towards and it'll do a different move
push it with down it'll do a different
move and so the combination oh I see so
you can bring them in a combo exactly
exactly and and so and you see there's
like a meter up on top which is
basically that that'll limit it so you
can't obviously fire them
indefinitely but um you call you can
call them pretty much whenever you want
and they have you know like in the
middle of a combo they'll have a lot of
um you know basically a whole arsenal of
their mood so Sony Utah come out there
sometimes you'll see them appear twice
in there to me so time base they come
out and then obviously as you go through
you revealed some of them there but is
it a different set of characters that'll
be in the cameos or there's some repeats
from the main roster how will that work
yeah yeah some of the characters are
going to be available as cameos as well
as the main roster fighter so you can
play Sub-Zero with sub-zero right you
can play you can same thing with
scorpion but a lot of our our Cameo
Fighters are kind of like nods back to
our first game so you'll notice Sonia
and Kano and Jax are in their kind of
older costumes and so there's there's a
lot of that novelty we have a lot of
like really surprised ones I think you
guys saw Goro yes
so there's a lot of like kind of really
digging into the old Mortal Kombat games
as far as getting you know um we really
love the novelty of it we really want
the Cameo characters to feel uh you know
kind of Nod to the old games
well speaking of uh 90 old games let's
talk you confirmed I think or at least
knowing that Jean-Claude Van Damme is
actually going to be in this game as
Johnny Cage right yeah
the story I mean Bloodsport was such an
inspiration for Mortal Kombat so he
finally is now yeah part of it it's a
huge first uh full circle moment you
know what the the first Mortal Kombat
game we originally wanted to be Van
Damme the video game and that and that
never really worked out so I I can't
tell you how many times over the last 30
years we've tried to get him
um you know we are this close like four
or five times and uh so finally we got
him and he's doing the voices too so
you're going to hear John Claude his
voice doing Johnny Cage lines and stuff
like that we're really excited about it
wow well I know the team has been
working so hard in Chicago to build this
through covid and it's coming out in
September so we don't have to wait long
right that's right with this this has
been a very difficult uh
secret to keep over the last over the
last four years and so uh but we're
we could not be more excited in terms of
uh getting players hands on it um and
you know throughout the summer we're
going to be showing a lot more content a
lot more characters a lot more Cameo
characters you know so there's a lot of
reveals that are coming up amazing well
Ed thank you so much for giving us the
first look at MK1 as you said this
weekend people will be playing at
Preston media so we'll be seeing lots
more coverage first look at Mortal
Kombat awesome
amazing so excited about that one all
right next up it's been a fun couple
weeks for Action RPG fans with the
release of Diablo 4 which is truly
fantastic another big and anticipated
arpg is Path of Exile 2 from grinding
gear games who have Faithfully been
updating and patching the original Poe
since its release in 2013. we haven't
seen anything on the sequel in over two
years but that changes right now here is
your first look at a raw gameplay
capture from Path of Exile to a sequel
that pushes the engine and gameplay to a
new level
[Applause]
where are the guards
hey you what's going on
[Music]
foreign
looks amazing and there's more coming in
July last week marked the release of
Street Fighter VI a game we featured
last year at summer game Fest well the
team at Capcom has an important update
to share with you right now
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
I am the advanced artificial
intelligence Leviathan
welcome to pikitola Island
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm guessing Ryu from Street Fighter
facing off against a dinosaur probably
wasn't on your bingo card for today's
show
that Street Fighter across exoprime will
collab will launch in the fall with the
game coming out on July 14th but guess
what guys that may actually not be the
craziest collaboration on the show today
check this out
there's nothing
can shave the fabric of reality
transforming everything you may think
you know
[Applause]
that's right Nicholas Cage is coming to
dead by daylight in July I mean I don't
know how these things happen but
I figured the easiest way to find out is
probably to go right to the source
this man's bold creative choices have
earned him an Academy Award and a few
memes on the internet across more than
four Decades of incredible films please
join me in welcoming to summer game Fest
Nicholas Cage
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you everybody thank you happy to
meet you Nick I gotta say welcome to the
Video Game World oh wow yeah thank you
I'm so happy to be invited to your very
very cool Club everybody
finally I mean I gotta say this is such
a crazy unexpected collaboration I gotta
understand how did this come back I mean
some people be like oh maybe he'll show
up in fortnite maybe he'll be in a hideo
Kojima game but dead by daylight I mean
how does this happen well it's it's a
museum of horror right and when I make
movies one of my favorite genres is
horror and in this and and in that genre
there's a character a murderous ghost
named Sadako who I think is amazing and
she made an appearance in this game so
that was good enough for me okay yeah I
mean that's what's fun is you're playing
one of the survivors in this game and
it's cool that you know it's it really
is this Museum of horror Michael Myers
you said all these different characters
all coming together
um and you do you you play yourself or
who do you play so I play this uh
heightened exaggerated version of a film
actor named Nick Cage
he's uh
into a location
things making a movie and instead he
wakes up in the fog and in the fog he's
surrounded by crows and serial killers
and it's rather amusing and there's
something about it that I think as a
Survivor is like a bonding experience
it's a bit like hide and go seek you
have your three other teammates who are
survivors with you and it's teamwork
you're working together to pull through
and I like that and so that was a large
reason for wanting to do it as well that
that feeling of bonding with your
friends and you're fully Infamous I know
we heard your voice in there so you
recorded lines for it and everything see
I want you to know when you're playing
the Nick Cage Survivor I even have when
you're choosing your skins I even say
always remember to dress to match your
talent I want you to know that you're
with me that we're one that were fused
and so it was important to me that
everything I do everything I say from
the scream to the grunt down to the most
minimal exasperated expression of a sigh
whatever it is it's my voice so that we
are fused all right
cage I love it I I mean
for fun this game as you said is such an
awesome kind of you know collaboration
with so many different characters for
you I mean how did you find out about
dead by daylight do you know much about
the video somebody very important in my
family is a dead by daylight Enthusiast
and and that really put the uh hook in
pun intended uh
uh see dead by daylight to me was an
opportunity to Branch out to I've never
been invited into this space before I'm
always looking for new adventures so
this to me was like wow I can I make it
I can make a whole new audience meet a
whole new audience and Branch out and go
on this dead by daylight Adventure I
didn't say it took me nothing but a
split second to say yes and speaking
about split seconds what excuse me what
I noticed excuse me sinuses uh allergies
what I noticed was that every move you
make when you're doing this when you're
in the gaming space it's it's time down
to the Split Second it's an it's a very
immersive experience when you're acting
out in this space because every move
every on every saw you make has to be
timed perfectly with the gamers move so
that was something that I learned from
this I'm always looking to learn
something well we love having you in the
video game where we want to see Nick
Cage and more games
[Applause]
Nicholas Cage great to see you man there
you go lock it in
now for all of you who want to play Nick
Cage in dead by daylight the chapter
officially comes out on July 25th on PC
and console but PC players can try it
earlier by downloading the player test
build on July 5th and here's an
exclusive first look at Nicholas Cage in
dead by daylight
[Applause]
thank you
damn right I made it
[Applause]
anything goes here at Summer game Fest
all right thank you very much Nick now
lately we've been seeing an incredible
number of video game adaptations but
back in 2019 The Witcher on Netflix
inspired by The Witcher book series
showed the potential of well done
adaptations and later this month season
three volume one arrives and now it's
time for the world premiere of the
trailer introduced by Henry Cavill and
the cast
hello Witcher fans we are all gathered
here today to share something with you
be sure to tune in to The Witcher season
three volume one day
volume one debuts on June 29th only on
Netflix get ready to watch the world
premiere of our brand new trailer for
season three of The Witcher thanks for
tuning in to the summer games Fest and
enjoy the trailer
[Music]
thanks
neutrality
it won't get you a statue
[Music]
but it'll certainly happen keeping you
alive
[Music]
I want abandon Siri
neutrality has consequences too
you're right I'm right well that's
deeply worrying
everything that's happening
it's all connected
I mean she's at the center of it
[Music]
if war is coming there is no hiding her
from it
sure about this
[Music]
[Applause]
history has a way of repeating itself
the dangers we've seen foretelling even
more menacing future
for the first time I understand real
fear
[Music]
foreign
I'll never get over how cute they look
for Monsters and they're like no please
don't hurt me and then wow
fangs just like a boatload of fangs all
up in your business
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
let's go
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
time
no turning back after this you sure
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
all right we have much more summer game
Fest to come including a first look at
the gameplay of Allen wake 2 the world
premiere of the new season of fortnite
Call of Duty season four and maybe a few
more surprises for you as we go through
today's reveals use the hashtag gaming
on tick tock on Tick Tock to react to
the news and we want to welcome everyone
co-streaming the show live on Tick Tock
twitch YouTube and other platforms for
those of you on Twitch we also have a
special Warframe twitch drop a free
steinax Warframe for watching more than
30 minutes of the show now speaking of
surprises another legendary gaming hero
is set to return later this year in a
brand new game built from the ground up
in a style that I think is going to get
this fan base and long time fans of
video games very excited here's another
summer game Fest Global game
announcement new Thrills with a classic
feel
[Music]
[Applause]
oil
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
how about a new standard for 2D Classic
Sonic that's bound to appeal to new and
Legacy fans alike
this past April honkai star rail
launched and as you're about to see the
game is bringing an exciting new
character to space fantasy RPGs however
we don't just have a new Peak for
current players but also for those
awaiting the game's release on
Playstation take a look
I wish this universe had a few more
things to do don't you get bored running
across the map every day
Trail Blaze back from Duty mission one
accomplished where's our next stop I
can't wait
another busy day ahead of us
[Applause]
[Music]
tournament's starting great let me get
warmed up
[Music]
strike first
need a hand my pleasure
let's see some Sparks Fly
huh
never mind I miscalculated
can you let me have some fun this time
[Music]
later this year on Playstation all right
inspired by the story of Pinocchio Liza
p is a soulsborne like game from the
team at neowiz which is coming to Game
Pass PlayStation and PC this year well
if you're wondering exactly when we have
news to share with you on its release
with this brand new trailer
[Applause]
[Music]
a little more
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
birthday
[Music]
s
listen pal nice landing but uh let's not
make it a habit
[Music]
[Applause]
that's right a demo for lies of p is now
available across Playstation Xbox and PC
check it out and prepare for the release
on September 19th now it's time for the
reveal of a visually stunning new game
based on a classic manga with a story
and World created by one of the most
celebrated anime artists of all time
this is one of those games that I feel
lucky we get to reveal for the first
time here at Summer game Fest and I
think you'll be pretty hyped once you
see the gameplay all built in Unreal
Engine 5. here we go
welcome
[Music]
[Applause]
she says you can bet on me it's always
better yeah
[Music]
thank you
sand land get ready to become an
unlikely hero and Adventure where you
don't need to be human to save Humanity
that's coming from Bandai Namco and
we're excited to see more of it soon
independent games are such an important
part of the industry and one thing
that's very important to us at summer
game Fest is supporting those creators
as well after the live show stay tuned
for Day of the devs from imapen and
double fine with some incredible indie
game reveals now one of the biggest
independent Publishers is Anna Perna
interactive and later this month as part
of Summer game Fest they'll be revealing
a number of ambitious new projects let's
see how many you can figure out in this
little tease
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
at the end we'll find out later this
month all right next we're stepping into
the world of throne and Liberty a free
to play PC and console MMORPG from
ncsoft and Amazon games with an
always-changing environment massive
scale pvpve and the ability to transform
into creatures to battle across land sea
and air here's a look at throne and
Liberty
our guiding star has shattered
its shards scattered across the world
an ancient evil searches for these lost
fragments
destroying anything in their path
you must find them
harness their power
and put down this threat once and for
all
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
looks great I also want to say hello to
everybody watching on Steam right now
I'm sorry we don't have any free steam
decks for you right now but on June 19th
steam nextfest does return giving fans a
chance to try out hundreds of new
in-development games one of them is the
free to play medieval fantasy sword
fighting game warhaven from Nexon which
lets you transform into Supernatural
Immortals here's a new look
hear the battle called
shitties
[Music]
and we keep on fighting
foreign
[Music]
thanks
faded
hey
[Music]
foreign
's summer is coming and we did a lot of
cool stuff will make his way to Dying
Light to stay human get ready for darker
more dangerous nights and roaming
volatiles complete with improved parkour
rolling out with the next update in June
then right after that we'll kick off an
even season like you have never seen
before trust me for one of them you will
want to get your butt Barbed wired very
soon you will get the deadliest Summers
to date
they don't care
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to summer game Fest isn't
that great by the way crash team Rumble
is going to feature playable Ripper Roux
and engine
neocortex's right hand guy in Season one
now it's time to change the topic and
descend into madness joining me is a guy
who was last on stage at the game awards
2021 to announce Alan Wake 2.
he's come all the way from Finland
please welcome from remedy Sam Lake
[Applause]
good to see you looking Dapper as always
thank you thank you well we are so
excited because when you announced uh
Alan Wake Up the game where Alan Wake
two at the game awards you said 2023 we
are in 2023 it's coming this October and
we are so excited about the Sam I know
it's been a long time coming for fans
and for you 13 years since the first
Alan Wake so tell us a bit about what
can we expect in the sequel it's been
quite a journey yet
um
Alan Wake 2 is remedy's first survival
horror game we have two playable
characters it's a 50 50 split between
them they are on their own separate
terrifying Journeys through two
different worlds and yet it's all
connected and the player gets to switch
between them at given points in the in
the story as they choose
yeah we saw obviously uh at the
PlayStation event you revealed uh Saga
the the second character uh tell us a
bit about her she's in bright Falls and
she's sort of living a narrative that
Alan has written is that right well uh
that's a good question to ask going into
this so yes we we have Alan Wake our
Title Character of course trying to
escape from The Nightmare dimension of
the dark place yeah and then we have
Saga our new hero FBI agent uh coming to
the Pacific Northwest small town of
Pride falls together with her partner
yes Alex Casey okay
so how and they're somehow linked in
some way right uh they are coming to
investigate yes a series of ritualistic
murders okay and and very quickly the
investigation turns into a nightmare
when they discover pages of a Horror
Story uh maybe written by certain
missing writer initials aw and and this
Horror Story starts to come true
around them interesting so obviously
it's you know Allen is still going to be
playable in the game you're going to
experience his journey but at Saga this
is her new character and there is that
sort of Link tell us a bit about you
said split 50 50 do they have separate
missions how because I think you can you
can play them in sort of different
sequences or orders if you want right
yeah we we go into the experience
playing as as Saga okay and and
it's uh sequel but it's also a
standalone experience we are not
expecting everybody to do homework okay
if they have not played the original
game uh this can be enjoyed uh as e Saga
doesn't know anything about the lore
about the supernatural uh in this world
she will be going in very quickly if she
has to learn to survive and with that
all the players uh will be on on that
Journey with with her and and uh then we
open up the experience so that you can
hope to play Alan Wake in the dark place
as he's trying to find his way out and
you can keep on playing as Saga in the
Pacific Northwest as the investigation
goes on and you are free to switch
between them there are a lot of
connection points yes uh in many
surprising ways but there is no right
way to play through this you can choose
you can go on as as Alan all the way
close to the end or a saga or you can
keep hopping between these two uh sites
well you're always so good at kind of
telling challenging interesting
narratives in unique ways I mean
remedy's always been known for that new
especially so we can't wait to see how
these stories intertwine I'm sure
throughout the experience today though I
know you brought with you some some
gameplay of saga's Adventure we're just
going to see a raw segment of the game
right yeah raw gameplay for the first
time ever this is early on from The
Experience they're hyped Sam they're
ready for it
so tell us what what are we going to see
uh
Supernatural policies of Darkness have
uh brought the murder victim uh in this
case Back to Life as a monster and and
Saga is outside Pride Falls at qualton
Lake trying to find him and stop him
okay with that let's take a look at Raw
unedited gameplay from Alan Wake too
thanks Sam thank you
[Applause]
sounds like somebody's home
that's okay
thank you
contest Nightingale
the text on the heart is clearer now
legible
I knew it would be here
so I've been a dream
[Music]
I'm glad you're on this case with me
Anderson
killer left a message
it's for us
we were all trapped in a horror story
The Horror Story wanted us dead
there's something
I'm forgetting
something important
something's not right
a long time coming but Alan Wake 2 looks
incredible thank you to Sam and remedy
for that first look at gameplay now
let's get a first look at the co-op
campaign of Warhammer Space Marine 2
from saber and focus
we're facing a tenant Splinter Fleet
they engaged us on two planets avarax
and kadaku
I'll be straight with you Titus I have
my reservations about your reinstatement
there can be questions will that be a
problem
no Captain
my pledge is
inbound
eviscerate this abomination
come forth and be slaughtered
open the gates
of that statue with a homosexual
for the emperor
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
beautiful indie game yes to your grace
snowfall now it is time for another
Global game announcement and this one
comes from the minds of saber
interactive Focus entertainment and yes
horror Master John Carpenter It's a
Brand New World a brand new story and
looks like a heck of a lot of fun check
this out
[Music]
nobody half ass
wishes
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
more unexpected collaboration Sean
Carpenter and Savor with toxic Commando
that looks uh tons of fun you guys think
any of those zombies made it I don't
know all right well this August brings
the long-awaited full 1.0 release of
Baldur's Gate three and today a new
member is joining the cast we're about
to see the reveal of Lord Ember gortash
the commander of a mechanical Army of
Steel Watchers he's a second antagonist
and is voiced by a familiar name
swear us thou by baldran's blade to
defend the citizens of Boulder's Gate
from enemies within and without
you are soon to witness the people at
Baldur's Gate granting me complete power
over there
a new age is upon us
gods have mercy on those who would stand
in our way a Mad Dog understands the
yank of the leash on the hand of its
master
cannot be an equal you can be my equal
there's an old wisdom a brittle Alliance
can never be mended it can only break I
want to lead this city to Glory I must
gorgeous Earth
friends allies to my side let us usher
in a new dawn this city is mine
I'm not ready to call you enemy what do
you say
shall we be allies
under control
it isn't you I answered to
gortash
[Music]
baller's Gate 3 is on tracks Fenn tells
me still for the end of August and we
can't wait to check that out all right
this fall Marvel games and Insomniac are
set to bring Spider-Man 2 exclusively to
PlayStation 5. sounds like you guys are
a little hyped to the tell us more is
Brian into Heart game director at
Insomniac Brian thanks for coming by I
know you guys are deep in development
first of all looks like we have some
fancy art behind us is this the Box this
is the boxer you know isn't it here it
is I mean
it has two on the box for a reason
because this game features two
Spider-Mans so we're really excited
about it absolutely uh Peter and Miles
uh we're so excited about this um you
know experience that you guys are doing
with these sort of two characters uh we
saw some great Gameplay at the
PlayStation showcase but I want to talk
about the two
villains I think in the game there may
be more there are more there are more
out there two main ones but uh we have
some new art to show of uh we obviously
Craven we got the reveal at the
PlayStation event so tell us a bit about
uh him and how he's Craven's very
different from any character we've done
he's not you know he's not powered by
magic or you know Tech he's just the
best hunter in the world and he's coming
to New York for his greatest hunt and
what's better than all of the Marvel
characters that live in New York City so
Peter miles and others he's on the hunt
and others yes but uh Venom also
obviously uh you know symbiote is a part
of this whole story as we saw in the
gameplay oh there you go
good reaction to the art uh
glad you're happy I don't know how much
you're gonna tell us about then is this
uh can you tell is this is an Osborne
Venom okay tell us what's the origin of
Eddie Brock Venom or it is not Eddie
Brock okay it is not it is not Eddie
Brock okay um our goal was to tell an
original story something you haven't
seen in the comics of the movies yet
obviously wow we love venom for a reason
yeah all those things you love about the
character are going to be there but how
the story plays out
who is Venom you have to play the game
to see how it goes yeah wow okay that's
there's a bit of a tease now obviously
the the Symbiote is a big part of the
gameplay and and one of the things like
we were all struck with the footage that
you showed at the PlayStation showcase
was uh you know how that is going to
really impact the gameplay when you're
playing as you know Peter so tell us a
bit about that and how you know the
gameplay is going to be dramatically
different yeah I mean I think you saw in
just the the raw power the strength and
even the transformation of of Peter's
moves in that in that in that gameplay
reveal you know he's you know we call
him the acrobatic improviser him and
miles but you can tell there's a lot
more strength a lot more raw power
aggression which you saw both in the
moves and how Peter talks so yeah it's
not just what happens in Game plates
what happens how the story plays out
interesting so that affects him as well
yeah I mean you saw some of that and
there's much more of that Journey when
you play the game and I know the the
journey is also more expansive you've
got Queens Brooklyn so even more of sort
of yeah I mean the city has pretty much
doubled in size so it's meant it's
Manhattan Queens Brooklyn and then being
able to use the web Wings to Traverse at
speeds way faster than they were before
um is really awesome hugely ambitious
game you guys have been building uh over
the past few years we saw at the um at
the PlayStation event uh it said at the
end fall 2023 and I think you know we're
like getting close to that are you guys
feeling confident that you're gonna make
it this fall
you know Jeff I know you like exclusives
yes
and I can promise you we are very
confident what we're going to tell you
right now oh yeah okay yeah let's take a
look
nail it at October 20th Spider-Man 2
exclusively for PlayStation 5. got it
awesome well Brian thanks so much for
stopping by I know you got a lot of work
to do wrapping up the game but we'll
check it out in October thanks Brian
we got our dates all right now let's
take a look at Power World a multiplayer
open world survival crafting game where
you can befriend and collect mysterious
creatures called pow who can also fight
in other words it's kind of like Pokemon
with guns and then
we're gonna look at the land of the
Morning Light a new expansion to Black
Desert online which recreates the
mythical folk tales from Korea's joseon
Dynasty and some huge bosses too
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
it is time we told it ourselves
with hammer and ax we mine and sculpt
across Middle Earth delving for riches
yet the greatest treasure remains out of
our reach morya
come my fellow dwarves
granny together
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
all right now we're going to look at an
exciting new mobile game from a
legendary franchise
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
ever crisis has just started and users
will have the chance to participate in
upcoming closed beta test now speaking
of Final Fantasy
no no no no no today during summer game
Fest doordash has your back get you can
get a free burrito when you order from
Taco Bell using the code gamefest plus
get the chance to win a final fantasy 16
prize pack doordash stay in your game
yep we got you all right now here's a
look at the game we debuted last year at
TGA banishers ghosts of new Eden the
story of two ghost hunters in the
haunted Wilds of North America
[Music]
life to the living death to the Dead
foreign
ers
we end suffering for those who live
we bring closure to those who don't
want us back red
I want revenge on what killed me
I want to live
as the man says we Face a choice simple
and awful
death to the dead
do we kill
to be together again
do we part forever
come out whatever you are come on show
yourself red
oh
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
mine on our
[Music]
way
[Applause]
good morning Stanley it is 7 32 a.m I
hope you have a productive day
change username to just Stan
adjusting morning wake up good morning
just stand race to capsule 12 come in
you there stand green across the board
looks like we're good
[Music]
definitely a lake here Tim
and how long has it been now three years
months in 17 days
what sort of operation are they running
down here
they shouldn't be here
this doesn't make sense
someone else down here
[Music]
no no no no no no
are you there
all right
it's a beautiful new game under the
waves and today incidentally is World
ocean day fun fact all right next Call
of Duty well there's a new Call of Duty
coming this fall along with Warzone
Mobile today we're going to give you the
first ever look at season four of Modern
Warfare 2 war zone launching next week
here's your first look at vondel a new
War Zone location with points of
interest including medieval castle a
soccer stadium and an abandoned Zoo yep
it's all happening check it out here you
go
foreign
[Music]
whoa
season four next week today is a big day
for video games but also a huge day for
Porsha the iconic German automaker
turned 75 years old today and to
celebrate their contributions in the
automotive and gaming space and we've
all raced a 911 in some point at a game
Xbox has teamed up with Porsha for a
limited edition run of 75 consoles
inspired by six famous Porsche race cars
and I'm thrilled to debut the first
design here today inspired by the
Porsche 963 that's racing this weekend
at the 100th running of the 24 Hours of
Le Mans let's take a look
[Music]
thank you
and here it is the Porsche Xbox series X
these custom consoles are not for sale
but you can enter for a chance to win
one right now at Porsche Xbox
sweepstakes.com make sure to stay tuned
for the Porsche and Xbox social channels
for additional opportunities to get your
hands on these special consoles all
right next Phoenix labs are building the
next great entry into the Cozy Farm Sim
John we all like a cozy game inspired by
Classics like Animal Crossing and
stardew Valley previously announced for
Nintendo switch there's now some
exciting news for PC players too let's
take a look at Faith Farm
dear friend life in azorious been
treating me well
days pass so quickly
before I know it they turn into Seasons
[Music]
it's been a breath of fresh air
I think we found a way to get cozy and
settle in
but there's something more I've been
itching to explore
Realms where magic comes to meet us
as long as we're prepared we can face
anything
so what do you say
there's so much yet to discover are you
ready
[Music]
we promise variety there it is Faith
Farm and Mortal Kombat in the same show
only at summer game Fest now please
welcome Ben brode Chief development
officer and flannel Enthusiast at second
dinner the developers behind the popular
collectible card game Marvel snap what's
up fans
man you guys have been on fire last time
I saw you was at the game awards when
you won uh best mobile game uh seems
like you've been very busy we're excited
about the spider-verse content you've
been doing Lots going on over there
right yeah it's been uh it's been
exciting we've been doing a bunch of new
features some of the wildest cards we've
ever made and uh um some new game modes
yeah yeah new game is that is that a
Segway Ben certainly yeah I'm excited to
announce Marvel snaps biggest update
ever uh we have a new game mode coming
next week it's Conquest mode it's a
great way to get a super competitive
experience uh in some exciting new
rewards but you don't have to wait till
next week if you haven't tried model
snap go down right now on your mobile
device or early access on Steam all
right I love the enthusiasm Ben
that's you you're made for YouTube all
right well we heard you brought uh
something fun uh with you for us to
watch right oh yeah so listen I am
incredible at card games so I often win
uh but some people and maybe you've had
this experience Jeff uh some people lose
yeah fair and I like to think it's
because they suck no offense Jeff
but sometimes sometimes it's because
there might just be a little bit unlucky
cue the tape
oh snap
okay I don't have an ideal hand of cards
here but that's fine I'll see what I
draw in future turns anyway let's reveal
the first location La muntus one each
player destroys their deck okay I guess
I will work with what I have I'll play
Medusa on location number two she gets
plus two power and let's see the next
location Clover Dangerfield has a 25
chance of destroying your cow okay well
I mean 25 isn't that bad and it's gone
okay well I have some powerful cards in
my hands so I can just wait let's see
the next location the Big Barn players
cannot play four five or six cost cows
also if you don't play a card this turn
you have zero friends
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
from EA originals and ascendant and the
world premiere first look at chapter 4
season 3 of fortnite Wilds now if you're
looking for the smartest way to level up
your gaming this summer compare top
credit cards side by side with nerd
wallet and start maximizing your cash
back rewards on everything from Wi-Fi to
headsets now here's a look at King
Arthur Legends rise a new cross-platform
ue5 game from mobile and PC a fantasy
Squad RPG Adventure that is available to
pre-register today
author
I have sacrificed everything to save
your kind
[Applause]
[Music]
Le fight with honor
thank you and
worthy of your legacy
[Music]
wayfinders
do you remember the fall
the Gloom descended on skylight
rally to protect the beacon
terrible price
and the world was broken
remember who you were who you are and
return to us
this world needs champions
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
project under construction
what do you say guys one more game good
morning scavenger
surroundings to retrieve and recycle
anything that could be of value to
scavax
[Music]
foreign
43152.4
our Fleet is cautiously entering hostile
territory
and the crew is standing by
[Music]
power
us
resistance
hey there summer game Fest 2023 it's
Will Arnett here yeah
right
um my buddy Anthony Mackey and I have
been working on this for some time now
we're really excited to share with you
twisted metal which is streaming only on
peacock starting July 27th and I'm very
excited to share a sneak peek of the
character of Sweet Tooth who I had the
pleasure of voicing hope you enjoy it
check it out
this is gonna be fun
swag a little wide there
well aren't we a tall glass of water me
I'm more of a Hawaiian Punch
I'm guessing you don't fight much
outside of your car now do you I don't
need four wheels to kick your ass
any chance we get this back in the cars
how about a little kill music
[Music]
do you love this over here God
this is a misunderstanding
I've been getting shot at ever since I
can remember
it's Fourth habit I guess sounds like
you have trust issues
[Music]
who hasn't dreamed of duplicating
oneself in order to multitask this new
hack and slash game with a tactical
twist allows you to do just that brought
to you from France here's the world
premiere reveal trailer of lisfunga the
time shift Warrior coming later this
year to PC
goddess of time
receive my life's less hunger let this
power flow through you and fight again
alongside your past sorrows
I'm here again
I'm not good
I rewind I begin again but with another
meat if I win
you're coming with me
[Music]
foreign
you're not the only one who can be in
multiple places at once
I will become Legion and Crush these
demons
onwards I can feel that there are more
foreign
game all right next up is a brand new IP
from ascendant Studios a single player
first person magic shooter called
Immortals of avium it's fast and fluid
it's an FPS in a fantasy setting kind of
like Doom with magic it also has a great
cast led by Darren Barnett as the main
character Jack and he joins us now hey
Darren hey guys great to have you with
us thank you this is such a cool game
super high production value spectacular
gameplay tell us about the guy you play
You're the main character Jack right yes
I'm playing the main character Jack as
seen behind me he's a battle mage that
controls all three forms of magic Triple
Threat uh he's Brash he's funny but he
gets the job done well uh it's the the
gameplay as we've seen is just so fast
paced there's so much action in it uh
you know with all the Spells the spell
casting and the magic what can you tell
us about the story and sort of how this
battle mage Jack uh comes in he sort of
becomes a battle mage right yeah he kind
of comes from nothing he's uh I guess
they call him Street rat is what he was
um but he yeah during a time of intense
trauma he summons the power to control
magic uh becomes part of the Immortals
which is like the elite Navy SEAL Squad
of this world called avium and they are
in the middle of an Ever War fighting
for the control of magic okay uh you
have a great cast you Gina Torres in it
lots of amazing actors in this
incredible really high production value
game that's coming out this summer we
don't have to wait long for it um and I
know you brought something with you to
share today which is a gameplay sequence
which one of the most epic sort of parts
of the game right yeah um so this is a
wild part of the game this trailer is
going to be showing you um The Immortals
and myself confronting Sandra directly
who is the top villain of this game
um and trying to end the ever war and
it's taking place in like one of the
most badass levels of a video game I've
seen we're battling on top of a 400 foot
Mech in the middle of the ocean as it
moves around
um it's wild so let's take a look all
right let's take a look at some brand
new gameplay from a mortal which comes
out this summer for PC PS5 and Xbox
thanks Darren thank you
andrax literally pushed us to the edge
everyone that can fight already is
[Music]
still losing
welcome aboard immortal
what's our bearings sir North by
Northeast five knots
we'll catch him so
[Music]
all right
get to the control room and protect
Selco and Dara and I will hold off the
roshanians down here got it
I gotta get to the control
[Music]
foreign
I want to
fight this war as one of you
you're what's called a try art
the pentacide has gifted you with the
ability
to manifest all three colors of magic
[Music]
we're only going to win this one
together
love that we get to show you guys so
much amazing raw gameplay today and that
game looks incredible coming out this
summer from ascendant and EA now one
game that constantly reinvents itself is
fortnite and tomorrow chapter 4 season 3
Wilds launches and today summer game
Fest is debuting the cinematic trailer
to preview the season the center of the
island has collapsed revealing a vast
hidden jungle with ancient secrets to
discover and of course there's a whole
new battle pass lineup where you can
Unleash the Power yes of Cybertron here
we go
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
night Wilds launches tomorrow
well finally guys
it's time to get to our grand finale
and it is a deep honor for me to present
this game what you're about to see is a
world premiere trailer that gives us a
new look at an expansive world we can't
wait to explore again
this game comes from a studio that
surprised the world and redefined the
RPG genre with its iconic characters and
Rich storytelling and I want to thank
them for this trailer for one of
Gaming's most anticipated upcoming
releases
the rumors
were true
we are still here at the scene of this
terrible disaster caused by a massive
tornado which swept through sector zero
one and two
amidst the wreckage of the expressway
search and rescue operations are already
in progress
[Music]
wow just look at it all it's so green
even after everything we've done to it
it's still going strong it may look that
way
barely hanging
hangings wondering what's Cloud been
doing these past five years where has he
been and you're asking me this
this is gonna sound crazy but
as far as I know
Cloud was never in miebelheim five years
ago
a live stream
the very essence of our star
the blood coursing through its planetary
veins
according to Hojo they're connected to
sephiroth
Shadows of the man I believe he called
them
sephiroth was in midgar we fought him
whatever happened he's alive but why
come back now
after five years doing who knows what
well now I think we woke it up
angered it more like
oh
lost your eyes on the Turks latest and
greatest Elena she may be new
[Music]
they say she's a monster
that she can peer inside you into the
very depths of your soul
that she can become those you hate those
you fear
those you love
marine and yeah
I've murdered my dad
you burned my Village
do you know that I killed her
so who is she
[Music]
[Applause]
there you have it that was Final Fantasy
VII rebirth coming early 2024 to
PlayStation 5 numero Sun thank you so
much all right that's gonna do it for
summer game Fest our live showcase but
that is not the end of summer game Fest
stay tuned this weekend for updates on
many more games during sgf play days a
Hands-On event for media here in Los
Angeles including cyberpunk 2077 Phantom
Liberty as well as the Xbox and Bethesda
showcase on Sunday right now though stay
tuned for Day of the devs from I am
8-bit and double fine which celebrates
the independent game culture with a
number of new game reveals over the next
hour
we'll see you this summer later this
summer on August 22nd for Gamescom
opening night live in Germany and again
in December when we come together here
in Los Angeles to celebrate 10 years of
the game awards thanks for watching
everyone we'll see you soon
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
showcase thanks to Jeff Keeley for
having us be part of his Summer Games
Fest and thank you to all of you the
millions of people watching out millions
of people God they can't be right
this thing has really grown since it
started 10 years ago here in San
Francisco day of the devs was a idea
from double fight Productions of the
friends that I am a bit to put on a show
that really celebrated video games and
focused on the fans and the developers
and brought them together to meet and
celebrate games it started as a live
event here in San Francisco where we had
developers showing their games where
people could play them and also listen
to music and eat food and drink and it
was really just a festival of amazing
creativity and a very inspiring event
and then during the pandemic it became
digital only and now we're doing both a
live event and a digital showcase so
people from around the world can enjoy
all of these amazing games we had record
number of submissions this year more
people wanting to be part of day of the
doves in any year previously and we have
more World premieres today than ever
before I'm excited I hope you're excited
and please without further Ado enjoy day
of the devs
digital showcase
there'll be effects on that it still
sound good
I'm pleased to introduce a brand new
game from a team that is near and dear
to my heart this is from Greg lovenoff
and the team at wishes unlimited who
made incredible games like wander song
and chicory here's their new title
Beastie ball
[Music]
I'm Greg labonov and I am bouncing off
the walls excited to finally tell you
what my friends and I have been working
on together ever since chicory came out
a couple years ago
introducing Beastie ball
Beastie ball is a turn-based RPG where
you coach a team of beasties to play
Beastie ball which is kinda like
volleyball you play as customizable
coach character and you can explore this
huge open world recruiting all kinds of
BCS to your team
then you can challenge Rival Sports
Teams as you rise your way through the
Beastie ball rankings
[Music]
feasties are highly social creatures
that evolved to play sports in their
natural wild state they're constantly
playing Beastie ball to build
friendships to sell disputes or just to
have fun when BCS play together they
actually become friends with one another
depending on their personalities and
their teamwork style they can form
different kinds of friendships
but whether they become besties or
rivals or Partners or sweethearts
they'll get some kind of unique combo
ability that only that pair of beasties
can do which can turn the tide in a
really tough match
[Music]
so with this game we really wanted to
emphasize the BC's agency as living
creatures they're doing their own thing
making their own decisions they'll only
join your team after being convinced by
you fulfilling a certain set of
conditions while you're playing against
them the goal isn't to collect as many
pieces as you can but to spend time with
the ones that you care about and be
surprised by the ways that they grow and
change and the bonds that they form with
each other
[Music]
we knew we wanted to create a really
wide variety of beasties that each have
their own ecological niche and way of
playing Beastie ball so we're working
with a really wonderful bunch of concept
artists and spending a lot of time on
each design all PCS have a range of
colors and sizes and their poses and
animations are all hand drawn which
gives us lots of opportunity to express
their personalities and their different
ways of moving to help give each BC that
personality we've been doing unique
voices for them each one can express a
range of emotions and we've had a lot of
fun performing that but it's not all
just friendships and rainbows this game
is about sports you come from a Tiny
Town built around a nature preserve
they're kind of underdogs until one day
when the Beastie ball leak shows up and
starts tearing down the preserve to
build a stadium your only way to stop
the construction is to rise all the way
to the top of the Beastie ball league
right from the start of your adventure
you'll be able to see all the ranked
teams on your map you decide where to go
who to challenge in what order and every
time you defeat a ranked coach the other
ranked coaches become stronger so no
matter which way you go you'll have a
tough and exciting rise to the top we're
so excited to finally reveal this it's a
really special project for us and if BC
ball looks cool to you too then please
check us out at beastieballgame.com
we're going to be reviewing a
crowdfunding campaign very very soon and
we'd love to have your support thanks
very much we can't wait to talk to you
more about Beastie ball
foreign
[Music]
breaker heart machine's follow-up title
in the Hyperlite Universe you'll assume
the role of a mercenary with some
serious skills you'll be entering the
overgrowth an amazing open world with
everything from Lush Rolling Hills to
deep labyrinths they'll be comprised of
both handcrafted and procedural elements
just how I like my levels like its
predecessor it'll be chock full of
secrets and lore sure to satisfy even
the most curious Explorer you'll face
off against enigmatic enemies armed with
an arsenal of weapons that you've
crafted with The Spoils of your previous
battles and for those Die Hard fans that
have been eagerly awaiting its release
we have some never before seen sneak
peeks this is hyper light breaker hello
I'm Alex creative director at heart
machine and we're making hyper light
breaker
[Music]
[Applause]
hyper light breaker is a huge stylish
bloody game as is our ammo it's a game
that's Vivid but Bleak with a crumbling
world that can be brutal and beautiful
all at once
it's a major landmark for us and the
first of its kind an open world game
where you never return to the same world
twice
I'd say it's a mix of incredible open
world games like breath of the wild
distilled into the format of a roguelike
such as dead cells or hands
you can play alone or with friends
cooperatively online
breaker's narrative will be presented
fully through Visual storytelling where
you'll discover and decipher the mystery
of this world and lost land from long
ago
every world will be different loaded and
dangerous creatures razor sharp combat
vast overgrown Wilderness long dead
civilizations and new discoveries in a
mysterious vibrant and horribly ominous
atmosphere
each biome in the world is different
with unique dangers set pieces and
stories of their own there will be
massive bosses to take down in an open
structure with dangerous unique and
challenging sub bosses scattered
throughout runs you'll pick up new gear
make new builds unlock new characters
upgrade your equipment as you bring back
more and more materials from runs
we've learned so much from our previous
games building up amazing Tech and a
deep well in knowledge and experience as
a team Breakers of culmination of all
that incredible work
we're excited to have you experience it
for yourself
we'll have a lot more information on the
game as we come closer and closer to
Early Access later this year
[Music]
and now in true day of the devs fashion
we're traveling Halfway Around the Globe
to Transylvania to bring you a game that
is not what you expect
from developer Stone Skip and publisher
I am 8bit presents I'm thrilled to bring
you a world premiere title that is not
only relaxing and enjoyable it's chill
and vibey let that anxiety go while you
play simpler times
[Music]
hi there welcome I'm Lara and I'm
dragosh of stone skip Studio we are a
small team from Transylvania and our
mission is to create meaningful
interactive experiences our first game
simpler times sheds light to the beauty
of the ordinary and serves as a place
from the past where it can be present
simpler times follows Diana heartwarming
Journey
man it's getting pretty full starting to
feel like I'm never gonna come back
we want you to slow down and
see its apple picking season my favorite
through Visual storytelling and mindful
interactions you will Journey alongside
her as she delves into her past and
uncovers her authentic self
we teach puzzle taina grows closer to
adulthood and you'll be there to guide
her from simple activities like picking
dried leaves from a plant to more
complex ones like building a birdhouse
you'll interact with objects that hold
sentimental value for China I really
wish I could save you with me I'm gonna
miss our Duets together
you know the world is
where players can take a break slow down
and enjoy something meaningful
simpler time stems from Stories We
Believe need to be told and heard
inspired by this very place we're now
sitting in the game is a reflection of
the physical spaces we spends timing and
The Memories We Hold here
I've spent so much time here looking out
the window it's hard to believe that I
won't see this view for a while
we want to build a sense of awareness
and appreciation for the world around us
encouraging you to reflect on your own
memories and experiences
SIM card times is coming soon on PC and
other platforms so make sure to wish
list on Steam and follow us on social
media thanks for taking the time to
listen we hope you'll enjoy playing
simpler times as much as we enjoyed
creating it bye
it's like childhood is the beach and
growing up is the sea
can I still take all these seashells
with me can I lock them in a chest with
my memories
[Music]
this next game is from sad owl Studios
and thunderful Publishing it's a really
unique puzzle game built around a camera
mechanic where the photos that you take
become 3D worlds to explore this is
viewfinder
thank you
we find this difficult game to describe
in words but if you saw it you'd
immediately recognize it
what is this place
it is a game that you know gives players
a lot of freedom
what's an old photograph doing here
you can take photos or find photos and
then
make them into real 3D spaces did hang
on did you just Shift Reality stick
what makes it unique is the central
mechanic where you're using a camera and
pictures to reshape and reconfigure the
world around you in order to solve
challenges in creative ways
it's such a unique experience and I
think everybody is just going to have a
different experience of how they play
viewfinder and that's just a really nice
thing to it
perfect fit
[Music]
hmm
that doesn't look right
take reality too
if I was to compare viewfinder to other
games I'd say it's like the gameplay of
portal combined with the visual
illusions of superliminal or ant chamber
people have also compared it to the
witness and manifold garden and various
other first person puzzle games
it's a puzzle game but it's very
sandboxy and playful and open-ended
the whole concept of when we started is
that when you actually create something
you do destroy a lot of things and you
know that's just a very important lesson
in creation
viewfinder is created by different
people and you know we have people from
all over the world who have such a
diverse and interesting cultures
each character comes from a different
culture this is where there's a lot of
sort of culture specific props and items
and themes who you learn about most
through environments and environmental
storytelling
and so we've tried to sort of make these
special spaces that really represent
that character who they are what they
like to do I'm sure you noticed by now
but using film was always mirin's idea
one of her many Passions
let's see Liam was always fond of games
it's just very important for us to just
put in what we know so that the rest of
the world could also you know have a
glimpse of the experiences that we've
had
this must be the next stage
let's go
[Music]
we received a record number of
submissions for this summer game Fest
edition of day of the devs but this next
game didn't actually come through that
process we have eyes everywhere and the
curation team is always looking for
games this next one actually came from
Twitter because the Creator was posting
all these amazing gifts and we reached
out via DM and asked if we could feature
the game so here it is this beautiful
gorgeous hand-drawn ghost story called
haunting
hello everyone my name is Leo dasso and
I'm with moon Loop together we're making
a game called Hunty
[Music]
the main mechanic in haunty is that as a
ghost you can hunt things and get access
to their abilities
there's a big variety of things that you
can haunt in this game
foreign
[Music]
sort of exploring around and seeing what
different things you can haunt and the
abilities that they give you
core mechanics resemble very much a twin
stick shooter however unlike twin stick
Shooters it focuses Less on the high
intensity moments and more on finding
creative ways to use the twin stick
Paradigm to create fun solutions to the
challenges in the game
Hunty follows the story of a ghost in
the afterlife and beyond that it really
expands into a lot of ghosts in the
afterlife and sort of the stories that
they have
[Music]
the progression and story of Hunty both
center around collecting these stars and
the stars have this special ability that
they give ghosts access to pieces of
their past life that they've left behind
the environments and characters are all
carefully crafted with a 2d hand-drawn
style so there's a lot of painstaking
frame by frame animation work in there
and we have a fantastic soundtrack
[Music]
so it all sort of comes together to give
you this sort of tour through the
afterlife chilled out experience
[Music]
if this is something you're interested
in be sure to wish list it it helps us
out a lot
[Music]
our next game is a bit of a blast from
the past it arrived on the scene around
12 years ago quickly became the Talk of
the Town and won a handful of awards
including the Seamus McNally grand prize
at gdc's independent games Festival but
then shortly afterwards both the game
and its creator vanished that game was
cartlife a slice of life simulation game
that put you in the shoes of various
Street vendors and tasks you with
setting up a successful business selling
bagels or newspapers
story unfolds you'd soon find yourself
making tough choices and trying to
balance keeping your business afloat
with the needs of your character and
their families
it was a truly unique powerful and
special game and it's super sad it's
been unplayable now for the better part
of a decade but it gives me great
pleasure to tell you that lovely
restored and better than ever cart life
is back
foreign
[Music]
hi I'm Nick Herman I'm with ad hoc
studio and we're here to show you cart
life
car life is a retail simulator developed
by Richard Hoffmeyer and was originally
released in 2013 where it won a bunch of
awards at the independent games festival
for a variety of reasons he ended up
pulling it off steam but all of us at ad
hoc are such big fans of Richard's work
now we're partnering with him to help
bring it back
in car life you can play as three
different characters in any Order each
have their own unique background and
circumstances but what they all have in
common is that they're trying to make it
as Street vendors Melanie is a recently
divorced mother and has moved back into
her family home with her daughter all
the while trying to establish her new
coffee cart
[Music]
Andrus is a Ukrainian immigrant who is
trying to put down roots in a new town
by opening a newspaper stand
and Vinnie has big dreams but never
enough money to make it happen he's
hoping that selling his homemade Bagels
will help turn things around for him
managing your own car is not an easy job
just like in real life in cart life your
resources are limited
you need to take care of yourself and
others and how you prioritize the needs
of your cart against the personal needs
of each character will determine the
outcome of their stories
the world of cart life is alive and
filled with characters who are potential
customers that you'll get to know as you
try to build your business
there's no right or wrong way to play
this game what players choose to do with
the time that they have with each
character is entirely up to them
everyone's experience will be different
based on the choices they make but what
they prioritize and even the order in
which they choose to play the characters
this release is going to have a bunch of
new story content new art updated
controls and mechanics and we really
look forward to sharing it all with you
on PC and console later this year
thank you
the skateboard Renaissance has been
going on for the last couple years in
games and as we get deeper into the
grind Revival things are getting a
little more avant-garde and daring this
next one gives you all that Tony Hawk
mechanical goodness that you crave but
with the heavy helping of demons and
brimstone this is the world premiere of
hellscape
[Music]
hello my name is Jordy vonenbosa also
known as kwebbelkop I'm the CEO and
founder of phantom coast and today I'll
be talking about hellscape foreign
first try here we go
no that was a good combo
all right that's it
[Music]
again
give me that turtleneck takes place in
first time here you play as Anthony
Falcon a skater through and through All
Anson wants to do escape and spare
time's fabled Beach even if that means
he has to go through the Gods and
Monsters who will do anything to stop
him and his skater friends from doing
what they love most
skateboard mechanics are very similar to
the arcade-like games such as Tony Hawk
Pro Skater I mean our lead game designer
Steve actually works on Tony Hawk's
Underground it started a long time ago
the idea and the far off far-flonging
land of 2002 I worked on a game called
Tony Hawk Underground and at the time we
were working on it we were thinking man
this really looks a lot like an RPG or
an action RPG you have all these stats
and you're upgrading and all this kind
of stuff it's super cool super neat
right but of course we're bound to Tony
Hawk we're bound to the real Pro skaters
it always seemed to me that the skate
Graphics create and imply such an
interesting world but it's not a
coherent world that you can visit so
that was one of the motivations behind
hellscape Hells Gate is a skateboarding
roguelike game it fuses together old
school skateboarding with the tricks and
traversal manuals grinds jumps bounce
meters with roguelite structure
just like with other games in the
roguelite genre death is a central
mechanic in the game
when you die in a run thankfully you
don't lose everything you keep your
resources which you can use to get
permanent upgrades such as tattoos or
skateboards which act as weapons
[Music]
the combat inner game can be described
as a fast-paced skateboard hack and
slash while you have your light and
heavy attacks the core of the gameplay
revolves around your skateboarding
tricks the game should be quite easy for
people to pick up and play it has a
combat system which is meant to be very
friendly very forgiving and rewarding
especially at the beginning and then
gradually it teaches you and ramps up
the skill of the skateboarding where you
need it when you need it
why did you stop me from skating
look at yourself your wing your arm what
do you think happens when that gets to
your head
[Applause]
thank you for watching this reveal of
Hells Gate which listening the game
would mean the world to us thank you
in our next game Henry halfhead you play
as half ahead
that's it that's the game but it's so
much more than that too because you see
Henry can be many things can be anything
in fact he has the Curious ability to be
able to transform into anything he can
reach using this peculiar power and
perplexing form you'll live the life of
the Title Character navigating sandbox
situations crafted by zurich-based
developers lululu entertainment and in
so doing maybe Ponder the philosophical
questions
who is
how is
what does it mean to be Henry halfhead
welcome may I introduce you to Henry
Henry's not just anyone if they're
anything there well everything Henry can
transform into everything in there yes
everything and that's how they manage
their daily life
the familiar noise of Henry's alarm
clock announces the dawn of a new day
and it will keep ringing until Henry
gets up and calms the nervous quivering
machine
foreign
[Music]
at least half awake Henry is ready for
their morning routine which they usually
start by making their bed
is tempting but only leads to regret
later Henry knows that if you want to
change the world you have to start off
by making your own bed because
completing this simple task in the
morning gives Henry a little bit of
Pride and the feeling of control over
their life
with part of the morning routine done
Henry was ready to freshen up
[Music]
for hours Henry could sit there lifting
the seat up and down pretending it was a
singing mouth
not too hot not too cold
Henry bought a turmeric soap they didn't
know they just like the color it's
actually great for their skin
foreign
[Music]
Henry is now ready for a proper
breakfast
with a warm beverage is important and so
is keeping up with the news
this week that's all for now have a
wonderful day
[Music]
the best drink Henry can make from Beans
candy of nature delicious
well-fed and well informed Henry has to
get ready and pack for work
foreign
[Music]
if Henry takes The Lunchbox and leaves
now they can catch the eight o'clock bus
the Henry double the fun
play Henry's not so ordinary everyday
life in Cold mode
Henry everyday life with a Twist
our next game is from Yepi Carlson a
Creator who's perhaps best well known
for his work as Master puzzle Creator on
limbo and inside
we have the honor of working with him to
publish two of his solo projects as part
of double fine presents Rhythm action
platformer 140 and Co-op arcade shooter
Thoth two of the most fiendishly
well-designed and fun puzzle games I've
ever played that truly give you a sense
for an appreciation of yepi's
contributions to those play dead titles
his new game sees him teaming back up
Jakob Schmidt composer of 140 and
applying his trademark puzzle skills to
a beautiful mind-bending Adventure game
this is cocoon
hello I'm janop co-founder and audio
director of geometric interactive in
Copenhagen I would like to show you what
our amazing team has been working on for
the last couple of years our game cocoon
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
cocoon is an adventure game with
multiple worlds and each of these worlds
are contained within an orb
let me demonstrate by jumping out of the
world which we are currently exploring
just like that we are now in a world
outside
[Music]
the orange orb here contains the world
we were previously exploring
this jump out one more time
we are now in a world even further
outside
and can explore this world using the
orange orb that we picked up
orbs can be placed on switches to power
devices and solve puzzles
[Music]
um
and you can even throw them into pipes
[Music]
foreign
you can use the hierarchy of foils
within worlds to solve interesting
puzzles
for example
we safely avoid this moving barrier you
simply jump out of the world
let it pass by
and jump back in
now cocoon is not only about exploration
and puzzles
within each world you have to face a
mighty Guardian
here is a first glimpse of one of these
encounters
foreign
[Music]
we hope you look forward to exploring
the mysterious worlds of cocoon
releasing later this year on Steam Xbox
PlayStation and Nintendo switch
[Music]
thank you
and now I'm pleased to bring you a title
from French Canadian developer
impossible in this relaxing artistic
exploration game you play a painter with
a watercolor brush and a whole city to
explore this game is more than
appropriate for Day of the devs summer
game Fest Edition because its title
ete in French translates to the word
summer
hi my name is lavlo and I'm the creative
director at impossible we are a small
Montreal based in the studio working on
our first Idol ete
[Music]
you see the world through the eyes of a
painter with every surface acting like a
blind canvas just waiting for you to
fill it with color
if they means summer in French because
it's set in our french-speaking hometown
of morial Canada as you step into the
shoes of a painter who's traveling
abroad for oil a summer this is a game
for people who love pure exploration
your freedom open City scenes at your
own pace following your curiosity
getting sidetracked and discovering
Secrets along the way
[Music]
when you fill something with paint
you'll extract its color as droplets of
experience and as you level up you'll
become able to unleash larger splashes
of paint that reveal a bigger part of
the world at once
foreign
[Music]
taking part in their lighthearted
everyday anecdotes and some of them will
even commission artworks from you
[Music]
using your bike you can travel quickly
back to your apartment and paint those
commissions on canvas
[Music]
that's where your creativity comes into
play
at your easel you can create gorgeous
watercolor artworks using anything
you've discovered in your Expedition so
far
steps on your canvas can be freely moved
resized rotated in 3D and even recolored
the canvas is pretty much your sandbox
that lets you put your own spin on
commissions and if you're feeling
inspired you can paint as many creative
artworks as you like without any kind of
limitation
with hundreds of unlockable stamps at
your disposal and dozens of commissions
to inspire you the only limit really is
your imagination
apart from living your best life as the
friendly neighborhood painter you'll
also get to meet other like-minded
artists like Mayan an ambitious
photographer and Theo a talented
musician among many others
if you manage to befriend them maybe
they'll let you in on their best kept
secret an abandoned building that could
become your very own painting Studio
but you'll have to dive into that story
for yourself it is coming out in 2024
and we hope you'll enjoy your adventures
as a traveling painter in this lovingly
crafted Whimsical summer world
hi everybody how are you liking the show
so far this is the time where we take a
brief break to talk about the long and
complicated process by which we accept
games into the nominating committee and
all the legal ramifications and the
technical rules that go with the
accounting of the Tim sorry I thought
that yeah I thought I was doing
something here too
all right
hey Kelly from Indie megaboth here with
a very exciting announcement
we're back
[Music]
if you're a fan of Indie Games you may
have seen the Indie Mega booth at shows
like Pax West and PAX East over the last
decade bringing together a curated
selection of the best up-and-coming
Indie titles games like Crypt of the
necrodancer tunic disco Elysium
Spirit Fair Celeste mini Metro
astroneer The Stanley Parable and papers
please have all been part of the Indie
Mega Booth Community if you're a Dev
you'll likely know us from our industry
work such as our GDC showcases our
presence at bit Summit are Global
Outreach and events including a robust
scholarship and grant program and if
you've never heard of any of this well
that's fine just think of us as like a
stepping stone into the games industry
where folks who love Indie Games can
connect with each other discover new
games and be part of a welcoming diverse
broad creative Community
Indie Mega booth has been in hibernation
during the pandemic but we are so
excited to announce that we're finally
waking up from our big long Slumber and
we're ready to move forward with IMB 2.0
head on over to our brand new website
indiemegaboost.com MB ND no by signing
up for our newsletter learn about new
games upcoming showcases digital sales
and the best ways to help support the
games and developers that you know and
love as we've always said in the
individually were tiny together were
Mega
foreign
we have another world premiere for y'all
and it's also really thematically
appropriate for this showcase uh you'll
see why in a second uh it's from the
aesthetically amazing studio called
lanency uh they're famous for the alto
series that you know and love but this
next one is not what you're expecting
from them uh it'll be hurting your way
it'll be flocking your way
no I like hurting
it'll be hurting your way next year it's
called Summerhill
it's about sheep
[Music]
hi there my name is Harry Nesbitt and
I'm the founder and creative director of
land and sea we're a small team from the
UK best known as the developers of the
Alters Adventure series
now over the last few years we've been
busy growing the team and laying the
groundwork for our most ambitious
project yet it's an entirely new IP that
aims to build on the themes that we care
about most as a studio and we're super
excited to be able to share this
exclusive first teaser with you today so
please take a look and I'll be back at
the end to tell you more thank you
[Music]
foreign
we hope you enjoyed this first look at
our brand new game Summer Hill to give
you a little bit more detail Simon Hill
is a story driven puzzle game in which
you play as a young Shepherd and their
dog
together you'll be setting out to rescue
your lost flock that have been scattered
across the mysterious land the lies of
the border of your home
Summer Hill brings together gentle
problem solving fluid herding based
gameplay and striking pastoral
Landscapes to tell a Timeless
coming-of-age folktale as a team we've
been massively inspired by the rich
history and cultural impact of sheep
herding across the world there are a few
people or places that haven't been
impacted in some small way by the
practice of sharpening even the name
Summit Hill is a name often given to
Highland passages where sheep are taken
to Graves during the warmest months of
the year
in many ways sheep herding is in our DNA
and we really want to do justice to this
Timeless tradition and tell a story that
could only be told in this way
we're also super excited to be working
again with our longtime collaborator
Todd Baker Todd is a composer and audio
designer best known for his work on
games such as Monument Valley 2 dreams
and our very own artist Odyssey
we can't wait to share more with you so
if you'd like to be the first to hear
about what we're up to please head over
to our steam page to wishlist the game
or go to Summit Hill dog game to join
our mailing list thanks again and we
look forward to sharing more with you
again soon
next up we have an update on your
turnites this is from Studio Sai
essentially a one-person team with a few
friends helping out on the side and it's
a dating action game now you've heard a
lot about this title uh sorry
what's happening
I'm sorry Greg I know I shouldn't be
interrupting day of the devs
but it's urgent
a virus has turned most of us into
I don't know how much longer we can hold
out
it won't be easy and the road will be
long but who knows maybe we'll find one
more thing Worth Fighting For
turn night is a dating action game that
takes adrenaline fuel combat and mixes
it together with a heartfelt love story
foreign
with all these infected
it's too much
and it's tearing these moments that I'm
happy to have someone to lean on
[Music]
for our lives solving puzzles exploring
dungeons
it all seems easier when you have
someone special by your side
to make things less scary
how
what now
[Music]
did you just shush me
a picture might hear us
hey
have you ever passed a note to your
crush
I mean four you you can just fight for
friendship that's cool and not
wow we are so cheesy
games we have so many mini games that
can help you unlock unique skills and
spells in battle
[Music]
so yeah you can fight monsters explore
dungeons
to date
I mean so many things like train
scavenge dance
twice anyway you have to manage and
balance all these activities if you want
to save the world the clock is ticking
okay cool okay bye
wish list now
next up from Italian Icelandic developer
evil licorice comes a Nostalgia fueled
Gadget building Sim that demystifies
Electronics engineering and allows you
to share your creations with the
community hello everyone I'm Marco
bangali from Evil Licorice and I'm one
of the designers of retro gadgets
[Music]
although it takes me forever to build
something like this I love the feeling
of seeing something happening on a
screen like this one when I rotate the
knob or I press the buttons and this is
where the idea for retro gadgets comes
from is to being able to build digital
gadgets with little effort
We Love pico8 by Lexa love because it
brings you this retro environment where
you can build your own games in Lua and
we also love shenzhenayo by Electronics
because it managed to teach you
low-level programming effortlessly and
retro gadgets tries to take the Best of
Both Worlds and adds a layer of Hardware
building and customization all this is
packaged in a cozy and retro inspired
environment
[Music]
we have a fantastic community and people
have been creating insane gadgets that
go well beyond our initial expectations
so please join our disco server and
check them out retro gadgets is in Early
Access on Steam and we have big plans in
store
bye
[Music]
if you've ever watched the Mars
Curiosity Rover on one of its missions
you very well may have become fascinated
by one of the hyper-specific
Contraptions and gadgets it keeps on
board to measure soil samples and hunt
for traces of water our next game poses
a very important question though sure
curiosity can tell us that whether on a
planet millions of miles away but can it
deliver a pizza
in Mars first Logistics from shape shop
you'll be giving the task of carrying
awkwardly shaped objects from point A to
point B by assembling and piloting your
very own Mars rovers and in doing so
perhaps you will solve a pepperoni-based
problems that truly matter
hello I'm Ian McLarty from shape shop
we're a small team based in Melbourne
Australia and we're making this game
Mars first Logistics
in Mars first Logistics you'll be
helping to establish a colony on the
surface of Mars you'll do this by
transporting often awkwardly shaped
objects between A and B using vehicles
that you design and build yourself
all right
as you complete deliveries the game will
give you new toys to play with
[Music]
the game is set in a vast open world
and you're free to pick and choose which
jobs you'd like to take on
there's a mix of procedurally generated
side jobs and handcrafted main contracts
in the main contracts you'll be helping
to construct new buildings in the games
world
[Music]
one of the main challenges in the game
is figuring out how to pick up each item
and deliver it safely to its destination
using the parts that you have available
[Music]
foreign
Parts more creative options will become
available to you
and I think a lot of the fun in the game
is just messing around and being crowded
in its editor
[Music]
and finally I'm really excited to
announce that Milestone statistics will
be launching into steam Early Access on
the 22nd of June that's just two weeks
away and we're really looking forward to
seeing what everyone builds in the game
thank you
[Music]
you'd think the aftermath of a worldwide
flood would be pretty bleak right well
UK and Denmark based Studio D guten
fabric has a different take from the
studio that brought you mitazione and
Sports Friends comes the all-new
Adventure set in this brawling
post-flood world of saltsea the
adventure unfolds differently with every
decision so there's always something new
to see in your next playthrough
so buckle your swatches and get ready
for the world premiere of the stylish
seaworthy salt sea Chronicles
[Music]
I'm Hannah nicklin from DQ de Fabric and
we made salty Chronicles
we're super stoked to show you the world
premiere of salty Chronicles today it's
a flooded World story driven Adventure
game where you play as a ship's whole
crew
[Music]
thank you
at the beginning of the game you're
going to discover that Maya your captain
has gone missing and together your
ragtag crew are going to host a ship and
set out across the salty archipelago in
search of Clues in each chapter of the
game you decide where to head next who
to explore with from the crew when you
get there and what to say to the people
that you meet along the way
salty Chronicles unique art style is
brought to life by beautiful animation
and each location is built on the
fragments of this world that came before
our art team have really done an
incredible job
one of my favorite locations is called
Los Gatos and on that island the people
there live symbiotically with this
community of cats
as you explore you'll find a brand new
trick taking card game designed
especially for the world of salty it's a
really good way to sort of take a break
from the story it's called spoils and
you can play it all over the archipelago
and you might discover how each
Community has slightly different house
rules
[Music]
another thing we're super proud of is
our exploration system so we're sort of
done away with the Walk of Shame in
adventure games so if you miss a clue
instead of sort of slowly tricks into
the other end of the island you're just
going to tap the shoulder button on your
controller or select a screen span Arrow
to move almost instantaneously across a
space it allows us to lay the story down
away from a linear path much more
organically
salty Chronicles doesn't tell a story
about a hero it's a story about a
community and how you navigate the world
together and each community that you
meet in turn is going to be rich and
amusing and strange maybe and have its
own things going on
there's also a strong sense of genre
based storytelling too so while you
might be new to the world of salty
you'll know that you're in a Scooby-Doo
chapter or a Romeo and Juliet chapter or
a detective one
there are plenty of laughs but tough
choices and meaningful moments too our
writer's room of award-winning
storytellers have done an incredible job
we're so delighted to share salsi
Chronicles with you all today and I
can't wait for you to explore the rich
World get to know the wonderful
characters and to hear what paths you
chart when you
[Music]
all right this next game it sorry
Tim keeps texting let's see
oh Tim wants me to read something
apologies but this seems important uh
the thing I love most about day of the
devs
says Tim as me as Tim I don't know is
getting to know all these amazing game
developers I love hearing them describe
their games and their creative process
but I wish I could hear more I wish I
could be a fly on the wall he's dropping
all their private conversations all
their ups and downs their triumphs and
tribulations while making a real video
game over the course of seven years too
bad there's no way to do it where is
there
this is actually pretty cool two player
Productions was embedded with double
fine for the course of seven years while
they were making Psychonauts 2 and they
made a Super Hyper duper long
documentary series unlike anything
you've ever seen in games all the
intimacy all the tears the outrage and
joys and and all the things that happen
in game development that never really
gets documented because who has access
like this so here's a very quick sneak
peek at their incredibly long series we
highly encourage you to watch this thing
it's it's amazing
so what's next second
[Music]
to get to the dollar amount we're
talking about it's probably going to
take financing from a lot of different
Avenues
whenever grasslands is going to start
Tim's is going to start taking our
people
so there's a ton of stuff going on right
now it's kind of breaking me but you
know it's fun it'll be really rewarding
when it's done
hopefully you get a chance to work on a
second game in the near future
thank you for helping us bring back
all right
to submit your game for future day of
the devs or to just hear about day of
the devs in general go to daythedevs.com
for more info thank you to all the
incredible sponsors that have been with
us since the very beginning
we're going on 11 years we could not pay
for any of this without these sponsors
they they donate to us ask for nothing
in return except to Showcase of
incredible games from Indie devs all
around the world so please Applause for
all the cool logos on the screen we
appreciate you we couldn't do this
without you thank you thank you again to
the incomparable dose one he's been
supplying the Beats for all the
transitions between all these amazing
games ever since we started doing these
digital showcases for Day of the devs uh
thank you again you're a hero amongst
Heroes go go check out his music it's
amazing just one is incredible thank you
for watching day of the devs yet again
if you're looking for more information
or you just want to subscribe to the
coolest newsletter in all the land go to
day of the devs.com the URL on your
screen follow us on social media we got
more coming up this year thank you to
our friend Jeff Keeley the summer game
Fest showcase was amazing we're so happy
to be a part of Summer game Fest for
these last many years definitely please
stick around we're not completely done
yet we have a musical performance
featuring the sounds of New Caledonia
thanks to our friends who made the game
Shia it's worth it it's really cool
happening right now
[Music]
your name is
[Applause]
[Music]
come on
anymore
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
whoa whoa
[Music]
stay
s
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
foreign
[Music]
I don't know
foreign
ER with up to 10 random players team up
and must combine the abilities of 50
different characters to win and complete
a loop throw yourself on a spike and lay
down an adorable little tombstone
Karma zoo is about helping people
working together and Finding Bliss in
cooperation even when things go wrong
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
hey everybody this is James Mountain
Community manager here at grasshopper
manufacturer and today for our 25th
anniversary so when do I get to line up
some demons hey what the hell man
hey what the bullet train is here maybe
I'm gonna blow your head up nicely no no
no no no no no no no no no no
[Music]
hey every demon has the right to pick
the music for his own funeral I do love
a party
okay
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
hey kids it's me Euro pal Volbeat your
favorite video game character remember
me I'm back
ten nine eight
eight seven
six
four
three
let's play
to generations of Gamers this is where
it all began
the cultural icon of the gaming industry
more influential than any pop star or
politician
the most famous video game mascot of all
time
devolver digitals very own
volvi
you know him as the star of all your
favorite devolver games but where did
valdi come from many years ago devolver
digital hired little-known designer
Jonathan schottfield and tasked him with
creating a character that could rival
the big names of the day you have to
remember we were trying to compete with
the Heavy Hitters Bank gex Awesome
Possum Errol the aircraft bad
and this is no small task
uh yeah we spent a few years on it but
to be honest I don't really remember
drawing it I remember Jonathan showing
us that final design it was a beautiful
moment
that face
those smart brown shoes
and of course
the master stroke is one big hand for
gaming I'd just never seen a character
with a hand that big
we knew straight away we had something
special volvi was introduced to the
world in his first solo game
field run which went on to become a cult
hit we were seeing the sales numbers
going up and up we couldn't believe it
the demand for the character was insane
I think it's supposed to be a rat and so
volvi went on to star in a string of hit
devolver titles Hotline Miami
Cult of the Lamb
Greece from nomada
Eighth House
my friend Pedro
pikuniku enter the gungeon the list goes
on and on
volvi's popularity had skyrocketed he
was an icon not just for video games but
pop culture in general
[Music]
the volvi merchandise was flying off the
shelves I'm talking clothing
toys
and even a range of what we called
legally edible snack foods
[Applause]
figure out what's in your mouth
but tastes and Trends are fickle and as
the years went by kids began to want
different things from their video game
mascots
we saw the way the market was changing
and we made the difficult decision to
part ways with ronoth we had no choice
we needed to keep volvi relevant
[Music]
cheeky smile I don't need your
permission to eat a meat Burger even the
big hand for gaming in favor of
something with more attitude
what I have an earache and I don't care
it's graffiti time looking back on it
Maybe
volvi 2.0 performed poorly and the
character began as slow but steady
decline
so
we made the decision to quietly
discontinue the volvy franchise it felt
like
I was losing a family member
well a distant family member but it was
still quite horrible
and um
nobody assumed since
until now
very very special night I'm your host
Chris Jake and you heard it right folks
I am so proud to present the launch
event for the reboot rebirth and return
of the world's greatest video game
mascot Volvo
oh yeah oh yeah okay settle down please
because it gets even better
ladies and Gentlemen please welcome back
valdi's original Creator rather than
come on Brian yes wow
oh my goodness Ron what a moment you are
looking fantastic please tell me bro how
do you feel right now on this momentous
day
very nice
oh wow that is beautiful that ad is
amazing and I for one cannot wait to see
what you and the team of devolver have
come up with so uh what do you say you
want to see him
ladies and gentlemen without further Ado
may I present to you the new and
improved valve
[Applause]
wow
oh my God he is back incredible but how
does he work
I'm glad you asked Chris
well we've taken the heart and soul of
what made Jonathan's character so
lovable but we've given him a very
important new update with the latest
advances in both biotech and machine
learning valve e fuses the DNA of a real
vole with today's most powerful AI
technology that's impressive yes
can instantly generate brand new fully
playable games based on simple prompts
by the player simple prompts you say
that's right the consumer no longer has
to wait for a bunch of slow programmers
and sting Developers
they can use volvi to play what they
want when they want
here let me show you hey there evolve e
[Applause]
[Music]
can read a game for me how about one
that oh I don't know is a Cooperative
survival sandbox but with Wizards
Maybe
[Music]
listen
and I'll tell you what to tell you
there they stood six alone the hunter
the maker and the wild swamps on the
young Chief resin and a weaver of boat
remembers
gay was thrown wide at the horror inside
before it was done our heroes yes
everyone
they found
[Music]
foreign
this is
[Music]
incredible
so wait a minute
are you saying that game was entirely
generated by evolve e no one has to
spend any time or effort making it
correct
there was no real creative process at
all just valve e and his wonderful
machine learning
huh
oh no well that's a good question
actually uh well each prompt and game
idea has to be digested by Valve E's
powerful system and so inevitably there
are some waste by products
uh so back to the games
um
do you mean to say that anyone can give
Vol via prompt
even I don't know
me
[Applause]
sure Chris see for yourself oh okay I'm
nervous now hi baldy Chris Jake
I'm a huge fan of the tal loss principle
so I'd like to see something like that
but with new puzzles a grander story and
big beautiful worlds to roam around oh
and I'd like to see that gameplay
right about
now
[Music]
I can't help but notice that many of
these structures are not strictly
functional
there's a sense of Aesthetics
of beauty here
[Music]
this place might be meant to test us but
perhaps there's more to it than that
what are we being tested for
[Music]
worth curiosity our
persistence
I keep thinking
puzzles
that just their symbolic value
because the thing about puzzles
[Music]
is that they can be solved
yeah oh yeah
wow now that looks like the kind of game
I could really spend my disposable
income on thanks volvi
and what happened to his big pen
and the best part is that to create a
game with valve e you don't need any
game experience or any of that type
stuff who here has interruptive creating
their own game I have
there
yes
come on up here come on all right okay
all right well oh and okay be careful be
careful no please please be careful
sorry that's just I'm such a big fan
all right so do you have a game idea
you'd like evolve e to generate uh okay
um how about a super weird walking
simulator where you control the
character's legs independently from his
body maybe there's some guys in horses
heads and possibly there's even a
mountain
right um but let's see valvi what could
you rustle us up
don't touch him
[Music]
Nate
Nate Nate buddy family meeting let's go
are you bringing a food not right now
not right now you are literally killing
him with these pizzas you just want to
throw
something
he's 35. I want him to have some kind of
discipline
maybe if you can hear my voice
a family meeting
foreign
[Music]
thank you
yeah can you not I uh uh just I didn't
yeah let's go back in time to when you
didn't no I I was just trying to catch
it with my uh sorry he tried to catch it
I saw it was starting to go and I just
tried to just kick you thought I'll give
it a good kick to counteract the fall
yeah I was just trying to steady it I
might go over yeah but you might have I
might have you might have oversteady no
it's just a little oversteady well it's
not steady now no well see you later uh
wanker yeah
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
you don't own any of the intellectual
property and you still have to buy it
okay give her a big hand
brilliant
so what happens if we bring a pro into
this
let's give volvi something really
special here
what's up guys hey yo hey how are we
doing guys I am watching live man can I
just say what you were doing out there
in incredible I could not be more
excited to be part of whatever this is
and thank you we're all massive fans of
your influencing what sort of prompt
would you like to give valve e here okay
try this volvi a much anticipated sequel
to a hilarious online co-op game just
more gameplay more levels just better
all around
okay Barbie show what you got
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
human fall flat too I know I'd love to
get my hands on a copy of that who
wouldn't right yeah come on well ladies
and gentlemen now that you have all met
the new and improved volv e it's time
for him to meet with you as we connect
him to devolvers Global Network of
gamers
once connected his powerful technology
will be an open source tool free for us
all to use wow that is generous here we
go
slight technical hit
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
merchandise right now buy it now a
dimension to Dover devolver Buy It Now
[Music]
thank you